One of my favorite things to do with my family is to go on a road trip. We are road trippers. Josh and I love to pack up the car and hit the road with our kids. And I just love the sense of adventure of exploring new places. And we love to use Airbnb. We love staying in a home. We love having a kitchen, having some type of backyard, our patio to sit on at night.
我和家人最喜欢做的事情之一就是去公路旅行。我们是公路旅行爱好者。乔什和我喜欢收拾好车，带着孩子们出发。我非常喜欢探索新地方的那种冒险感。我们很喜欢用Airbnb。我们喜欢住在家里。我们喜欢有厨房，有某种后院，或者晚上可以坐下来的露台。
I love the privacy of it. And also it just feels like you're still at home even though you're on this adventure because you make your own home. And you know, Airbnb is just so great for families because you can really pick a place that suits your whole group. You know, we did that one year with my family.
我喜欢它的私密性。而且，即使你在冒险，也会感觉像在家里一样，因为你可以创造自己的家。你知道，Airbnb对家庭来说真的很棒，因为你可以真正选择一个适合你们整个团体的住处。你知道，有一年我和我的家人就是这样做的。
We all met up in the mountains and picked this great Airbnb and all stayed in it together. Cousins and nieces and nephews and aunts and uncles. It was so much fun and it was so cozy. And Airbnb really made that family memory special. So use Airbnb for your next adventure. There's so many things I wanna do and see. Like redoing the basement without having to do it all myself. next adventure. Performance matter. And now you can get $300 when you invest with RBC. Offer ends March 3rd, 2025. Terms and conditions apply.
我们都在山里集合，选了这个很棒的Airbnb，大家住在一起。表亲、侄女、侄子、阿姨和叔叔们。那真的太有趣了，而且非常温馨。Airbnb确实让那个家庭记忆变得特别。所以，下次冒险就用Airbnb吧。有很多我想做和想看的事情。比如重做地下室，而不必自己动手。下次冒险。表现很重要。现在，通过RBC投资，你可以获得300美元。优惠于2025年3月3日结束。条款和条件适用。
Invest with RBC today. ["Jingle Bells"] ["Jingle Bells"] Dig out your ugly Christmas sweater because today it's second drink of Christmas party. Oh, I love this episode so much. I loved shooting it. I loved our breakdown of it.
今天就通过RBC投资吧。["铃儿响叮当"] ["铃儿响叮当"] 翻出你那件丑陋的圣诞毛衣吧，因为今天是“圣诞派对的第二杯酒”。哦，我太喜欢这一集了。我喜欢拍摄它的过程。我喜欢我们对它的解析。
But Angela, you told me you found something crazy in the candy bag alt for this episode. I did. So when we first broke down this episode, I didn't check the candy bag alts. And I thought this time, you know, I'd go back and see if there was anything I missed and oh my God, buckle in. What is it? You have not told me what is it. No. So remember when Michael buys all the vodka for the party, well, Meredith had a talking head about it.
但是安吉拉，你告诉我你在这一集的糖果袋备选片段里发现了一些疯狂的东西。是的。所以当我们第一次解析这一集时，我没有检查糖果袋备选片段。我想这次，你知道，我会回去看看有没有什么遗漏的，天哪，系好安全带。是什么？你还没告诉我，是什么？不。所以记得迈克尔为派对买了所有的伏特加吗，梅雷迪思对此有一个谈话片段。
Let's hear it. The deal is that this is my last hurrah because I'd made a new year's resolution that I'm not going to drink anymore during the week. Okay. So there were candy bag alts for that? Yes, there were several candy bag alts for it. Here was one of them. Meredith would have said, yeah, I like to drink. And if I get too drunk, I'll just have my 14-year-old
让我们听听。重点是这是我的最后狂欢，因为我下定决心新年不再在工作日喝酒了。好吧。所以那段有糖果袋备选片段？是的，有几个糖果袋备选片段。这是其中之一。梅雷迪思本会说，是的，我喜欢喝酒。如果我喝得太醉，我就让我14岁的儿子
pick me up. He has his tractor license now. Oh, I don't quite see how that fits. But that's not all. Okay. That candy bag alt led to a candy bag alt tag ending of the episode. Was it her son picking her up on a tractor? It read like this. Exterior, Dunder Mifflin night. Shot from inside. The parking lot is empty. A giant backhoe rumbles into the parking lot, driven by Meredith's 14-year-old son.
来接我。他现在有拖拉机驾照了。哦，我不觉得这怎么合适。但这还不是全部。好吧。那个糖果袋备选片段引出了这一集的一个糖果袋备选标签结尾。是她儿子开拖拉机来接她吗？它是这样写的。外景，邓德·米夫林，夜晚。从内部拍摄。停车场是空的。一辆巨大的反铲挖土机轰鸣着进入停车场，由梅雷迪思14岁的儿子驾驶。
We pan over to see a wobbly, still topless Meredith wander out of the building and move towards the backhoe. Meredith's son, Mom, what are you doing? She approaches the huge dirt mover thing on the front of the backhoe and starts to climb in it. Meredith says, Did you remember to put a pillow in the big basket? Meredith's son says, yes, mom. Meredith gets in and lies down. The backhoe starts to pull away. Did we shoot that?
镜头平移，看到摇摇晃晃、依然赤裸上身的梅雷迪思从大楼里走出来，走向挖土机。梅雷迪思的儿子：妈妈，你在干什么？她走近挖土机前部巨大的铲斗，开始爬进去。梅雷迪思说：你记得在那个大篮子里放个枕头吗？梅雷迪思的儿子说：是的，妈妈。梅雷迪思躺了进去。挖土机开始驶离。我们拍了吗？
This is a candy bag alt. I don't know. There's no way we shot it. OK. That, no. But if they had picked the candy bag alt talking head, would we have shot this tag? I, no, no.
这是一个糖果袋备选片段。我不知道。我们不可能拍了。好吧。那，不。但如果他们选了那个糖果袋备选谈话片段，我们会拍这个标签吗？我，不，不。
This is the writers, it was late, they were punchy, and this is what happened. They're like, Meredith's gonna climb topless into a backhoe? No, no. No, it did not happen, but I couldn't believe that when I read it. Well, lady, this episode also features
这是编剧们写的，当时很晚了，他们很疲惫，这就是发生的事情。他们想，梅雷迪思要赤裸上身爬进挖土机？不，不。不，这没发生，但我读到的时候简直不敢相信。好吧，女士，这一集还有
the famous Yankee swap gift exchange. People are getting gifts. They're swapping gifts. And we had a fan catch from Elizabeth H. who wrote in to say, in the gift exchange, Jim gets Creed's old shirt, but ends up with the Shamrock key chain. So I want to know who stole Creed's old shirt from Jim, right?
著名的“洋基交换”礼物交换。人们在拿礼物。他们在交换礼物。我们收到了一位粉丝伊丽莎白·H的反馈，她写道：在礼物交换中，吉姆拿到了克里德的旧衬衫，但最后拿到了三叶草钥匙扣。所以我很想知道是谁从吉姆那里偷走了克里德的旧衬衫，对吧？
Because that's the only way Jim would get another gift. Exactly. Well, Angela, I remember when we recorded this episode, you had just gotten a DVD player, and you could finally watch the deleted scenes, and you were so tickled because there was a lot for this episode, and I believe Elizabeth's question is answered in a deleted scene.
因为那是吉姆能拿到另一份礼物的唯一途径。没错。好吧，安吉拉，我记得当我们录制这一集时，你刚买了一个DVD播放机，你终于可以看删减片段了，你当时非常高兴，因为这一集有很多删减片段，我相信伊丽莎白的问题在删减片段里得到了回答。
It is. So there's a scene with Ryan and Toby I believe Elizabeth's question is answered in a deleted scene. It is. So there's a scene with Ryan and Toby where Ryan shares that he got Creed's old shirt. He said, well, you know, I figure I'll just maybe give it to a homeless person. Okay, so Ryan stole Creed's shirt from Jim. I guess so. Okay. And then there's this great little scene between Oscar and Creed.
确实。所以有一个瑞安和托比的场景，我相信伊丽莎白的问题在删减片段里得到了回答。确实。所以有一个瑞安和托比的场景，瑞安分享说他拿到了克里德的旧衬衫。他说，嗯，你知道，我想我可能就把它给一个无家可归的人吧。好吧，所以瑞安从吉姆那里偷了克里德的衬衫。我想是吧。好吧。然后奥斯卡和克里德之间有一个很棒的小场景。
I just loved it, lady. I know it's not exactly about this question, but I want you to hear it. Okay. What'd you end up with? Your Char radio. You like music at least? I love it.
我太喜欢了，女士。我知道这不完全是关于这个问题，但我希望你听听。好吧。你最后拿到了什么？你的收音机。你至少喜欢音乐吗？我喜欢。
I actually used to have a radio show back in the 70s. Kidding. What was your DJ name? Wacky Weed Creed. Wait, is that true? Alright. Is that a true thing? This is like what I was wondering. So, I basically started this just wanting to answer Elizabeth's question.
我其实在70年代做过广播节目。开玩笑的。你的DJ名字叫什么？古怪杂草克里德（Wacky Weed Creed）。等等，那是真的吗？好吧。那是真的吗？这就像我一直在想的事情。所以，我基本上开始这个就是想回答伊丽莎白的问题。
Yes. And I was like, okay, now I've got to reach out to Creed. I mean, I've got to find this out. So I said, Credo, it's Pumpkin. Random question for you. Did you really have a radio show and was your DJ name Wacky Weed Creed? And? He wrote back, that's so funny. Oscar asked me that on The Office. He said, oh no, hon, that was scripted. But I did do a Chinese TV show that became very popular over there. Yes, he talked about that on the podcast.
是的。我就想，好吧，现在我得联系克里德。我的意思是，我得弄清楚这件事。所以我说，克里多，我是南瓜。问你个随机问题。你真的做过广播节目吗，你的DJ名字叫“古怪杂草克里德”吗？然后呢？他回信说，太搞笑了。奥斯卡在《办公室》里也问过我。他说，哦不，亲爱的，那是剧本写的。但我确实做过一个在中国很受欢迎的电视节目。是的，他在播客里谈到过那个。
Captain Clark was his character's name. So this was all the writers. But isn't that a fun nugget? Very fun. And we also find out what Creed got. Well, this is the thing about the character of Creed. The line is blurry. You don't know. Sometimes he said stuff that was really about his real life. I know. But don't you love that he thought I was asking for real? Yes. Lastly, lady, I have a really fun fan catch by Kelly N. It cracked me up. Okay. So you know, Jenna, as you and I have been rewatching
克拉克船长是他角色的名字。所以这全是编剧写的。但这难道不是一个有趣的片段吗？非常有趣。而且我们也发现了克里德拿到了什么。嗯，这就是克里德这个角色的特点。界限很模糊。你不知道。有时他说的话确实是关于他真实生活的。我知道。但你不觉得他以为我是真的在问，这很可爱吗？是的。最后，女士，我有一个来自凯利·N的非常有趣的粉丝反馈。它让我笑死了。好吧。所以你知道，珍娜，正如你和我一直在重温
this, we have noted that John says D white instead of Dwight. He says D-White, like it's two syllables. Yes, you pointed this out. Yeah. Well, Kelly says in this episode, John says something instead of something. He says something? Sun thing. Okay. Sun thing.
这个节目，我们注意到约翰说的是“D white”而不是“Dwight”。他说D-White，好像有两个音节。是的，你指出了这一点。是的。好吧，凯利说在这一集里，约翰把“something”说成了“something”。他说“something”？Sun thing。好吧。Sun thing。
Well, I looked at the transcript for the episode and he only says something once in the entire episode. It's in a talking head about Creed shirt. Let's hear it. And you guys tell me what you think. Do you hear something or something? He obviously forgot to get me something. And then he went into his closet and dug out this little number
好吧，我看了这一集的剧本，他在整集里只说了一次“something”。是在关于克里德衬衫的谈话片段里。让我们听听。你们告诉我你们觉得是什么。你们听到的是“something”还是“something”？他显然忘了给我买点什么。然后他走进他的衣橱，翻出了这件小东西
and then threw it in a bag. Yep. That's exactly what happened. I hear something. What do you hear, Sam? I hear something. Cassie? happened. I hear something. What do you hear, Sam? I hear something. Cassie? Yeah, I hear something.
然后把它扔进了一个袋子里。是的。事情就是这样发生的。我听到的是“something”。你听到的是什么，萨姆？我听到的是“something”。凯西？发生了。我听到的是“something”。你听到的是什么，萨姆？我听到的是“something”。凯西？是的，我听到的是“something”。
I kinda hear something. You do? A little bit. I don't hear it. He obviously forgot to give me something. Oh. And then he went into his- Something.
我有点听到的是“something”。你听到了？有一点。我没听到。他显然忘了给我买点什么。哦。然后他走进他的——Something。
He obviously forgot to give me something. Well, Kelly, I don't know, three to one. Sorry. I think I need to hear him say something more. So maybe I'll start tracking it. Oh lady. Don't do that to yourself. Is it too late?
他显然忘了给我买点什么。好吧，凯利，我不知道，三比一。抱歉。我想我需要听他多说几次“something”。所以也许我会开始追踪它。哦，女士。别那样折磨自己。太晚了吗？
Is it too late? Don't do that to yourself. Don't. Hey, you know what? What? When we do all about Jim, I'm gonna see if he says. When you deep dive Jim Helper, you're gonna listen for something.
太晚了吗？别那样折磨自己。别。嘿，你知道吗？什么？当我们做“关于吉姆的一切”时，我会看看他是否说了。当你深入挖掘吉姆·哈珀时，你会留意“something”。
Something. All right. Well everyone, that was our second drink. And now here is Christmas Party. ["CHRISTMAS PARTY"] I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together.
Something。好吧，各位，那是我们的第二杯酒。现在是“圣诞派对”。["圣诞派对"] 我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hi everyone.
我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个亲历者才能为你讲述的独家幕后故事。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个亲历者才能为你讲述的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好。
Ho, ho, ho. This is a big episode. It's the Christmas episode. It's the Christmas episode. The very first Christmas episode of The Office, season two, episode 10. You know, it's not, we call it the Christmas episode. Yeah, we do. Or Christmas episode, but it is technically called Christmas party.
吼，吼，吼。这一集很重要。这是圣诞特辑。这是圣诞特辑。《办公室》的第一集圣诞特辑，第二季第10集。你知道，不是，我们叫它圣诞特辑。是的，我们叫。或者圣诞特辑，但它正式的名字叫“圣诞派对”。
What? Yeah, that's the name of this episode. I don't believe you. Christmas party. I don't believe you. No, I'm kidding. We did. We call it, we call it the Christmas episode.
什么？是的，那是这一集的名字。我不相信你。圣诞派对。我不相信你。不，我开玩笑的。我们确实。我们叫它，我们叫它圣诞特辑。
We call it the Christmas episode. We call it the Christmas episode. Even though there were many more, this is the Christmas episode. I have so much to say. I have 12 typed pages today. It looks like you're holding like a mini phone book. I feel like I'm holding a one act play or something. It's very large. And when I came in today, I will share that I refuse to speak to anyone because I said
我们叫它圣诞特辑。我们叫它圣诞特辑。尽管后来还有很多集，但这才是圣诞特辑。我有太多话要说了。我今天打了12页纸。看起来你拿着一本迷你电话簿。我觉得我拿着一部独幕剧什么的。它非常大。今天我进来的时候，我要分享的是我拒绝和任何人说话，因为我说
I was saving it for the mic and I'm saving it for the mic. She did. I tried to make it so I'll talk with saving it for the mic and I'm saving it for the mic. She did. I tried to make some talk with her and she's like, I'm saving it for the mic. I was like, okay, lady, you do you. I just, I just going to tell you, I liked your hair. I am. Well, you've got little pigtails today and they're real cute. I have plaits. What are plaits? That's what they say in the UK. They're like, oh, look at your plaits. Oh yeah. They also call bangs fringe. I know, I like it. I don't know if you noticed my side of the table. Totally filled with note cards.
我要把它留给麦克风，我要把它留给麦克风。她确实这么做了。我试着和她说话，她说“我要把它留给麦克风”。我说，好吧，女士，你做你自己吧。我只是，我只是想告诉你，我喜欢你的发型。我是。嗯，你今天扎了小辫子，真的很可爱。我有辫子。什么是辫子？那是英国人的说法。他们会说，哦，看你的辫子。哦，是的。他们还把刘海叫作“fringe”。我知道，我喜欢。我不知道你有没有注意到我桌子这边。完全堆满了笔记卡。
By my side of the table, you guys, I've made a buffet of note cards. Like I actually have to be aware, like Sam is saying to stay in front of the microphone because I have so many cards, I'm gonna have to slide back and forth down my buffet of cards. You love a buffet.
在我的桌子这边，伙计们，我做了一个笔记卡自助餐。就像我实际上必须注意，就像萨姆说的那样，要待在麦克风前面，因为我有太多的卡片，我必须在我的卡片自助餐上滑来滑去。你喜欢自助餐。
I love a buffet baby. Even if it's note cards. Give me buffet of cards. You love a buffet. I love a buffet, baby! Even if it's not cards. Give me that Vegas buffet. All right, Christmas Party written by Mike Shore and directed by Charles McDougall. Here's a synopsis. It's Christmas at Dunder Mifflin. Today is the day of the office holiday party. The group originally plans to have a secret Santa gift exchange, but when Michael doesn't
我喜欢自助餐，宝贝。即使是笔记卡。给我来一份卡片自助餐。你喜欢自助餐。我喜欢自助餐，宝贝！即使不是卡片。给我那个拉斯维加斯的自助餐。好吧，圣诞派对，由迈克·舒尔编写，查尔斯·麦克杜格尔执导。这是剧情简介。邓德·米夫林迎来了圣诞节。今天是办公室节日派对的日子。大家原本计划进行秘密圣诞老人礼物交换，但当迈克尔不
like his gift, he turns it into a Yankee swap. This causes a multitude of confusion and hurt feelings, and Michael's solution is then to go out and buy booze, which is against company rules, and to try to get the party back on track. 15 bottles of vodka. That'll do it. Fast fact number one, as I've already said, it's our very first Christmas episode, but we filmed it nowhere near Christmas.
喜欢他的礼物时，他把它变成了“洋基交换”。这导致了大量的混乱和受伤的感情，迈克尔的解决方案是出去买酒，这违反了公司规定，并试图让派对回到正轨。15瓶伏特加。那应该够了。第一个事实，正如我已经说过的，这是我们的第一集圣诞特辑，但我们拍摄的时候离圣诞节还很远。
No, you never do because you have to stay ahead. So you're always, it's like Christmas in July kind of thing. Well, we had a fan question from Sarah McGreen, did US cast members ever have Christmas parties or do a Yankee swap? And if so, what was the best funniest gift someone brought? A lot of people also ask if we exchanged gifts as a cast. Not at the holidays. We would do what's called a wrap gift, which happens at the end of the season.
不，你永远不会，因为你必须保持领先。所以你总是，就像七月的圣诞节那种感觉。好吧，我们收到了萨拉·麦克格林的一个粉丝提问，美国演员们有没有举办过圣诞派对或进行过洋基交换？如果有，最好的、最有趣的礼物是什么？很多人也问我们演员之间是否交换礼物。不在节日期间。我们会做所谓的“杀青礼物”，发生在季末。
And we would usually finish filming our seasons in like what, April? And then the cast would get together and we'd pool our money and we would buy the crew. Every member of the crew would get a gift from the cast. And then sometimes cast members would give each other wrap gifts. Little individual gifts. I did host a Yankee Swap Christmas party and I did it every year for a few years.
我们通常在四月左右完成拍摄？然后演员们会聚在一起，我们凑钱买给剧组。每一位剧组成员都会收到演员们送的礼物。有时演员们也会互相送杀青礼物。小小的个人礼物。我确实举办过洋基交换圣诞派对，而且连续几年每年都办。
And I actually wanna bring it back. I took a few years off because just, you know, life, kids and you know, stuff like that. But I hosted a Yankee swap party every year. And oh, yes, you did. And it was a big party and everyone would come and it got so rowdy. Yeah. My favorite person to have at a Yankee swap party. Yes. Is Oscar Nunez. I was gonna say Oscar. Oscar. He makes up chance. Like, like I remember one of the gifts was like a really lusciously thick fake ponytail. Uh huh. That you ended up getting. I took that home. Yeah. And Oscar like started chants like ponytail, pony. I mean, they're not really creative chance, but you'd be surprised
我其实想把它带回来。我停办了几年，因为，你知道，生活、孩子之类的。但我每年都举办洋基交换派对。哦，是的，你办过。那是一个大型派对，每个人都会来，而且变得非常吵闹。是的。我在洋基交换派对上最喜欢的人。是的。是奥斯卡·努涅斯。我正要说奥斯卡。奥斯卡。他会编口号。就像，我记得其中一个礼物是一个非常浓密的人造马尾辫。嗯哼。最后被你拿到了。我把它带回家了。是的，奥斯卡开始喊口号，比如“马尾辫，马尾”。我的意思是，它们不是很有创意的口号，但你会惊讶
how much they catch on. I remember one year Lee brought a small hand axe. That thing was super popular. The hot was super popular. Yes. I want to put it out there, guys, if you're going to a Yankee swap, consider bringing a small axe. Didn't the next year Lee brought a brand new water hose? A garden hose.
它们有多流行。我记得有一年李带了一把小手斧。那东西超级受欢迎。那把斧头超级受欢迎。是的。我想告诉大家，伙计们，如果你要去参加洋基交换，考虑带一把小斧头。第二年李不是带了一根全新的水管吗？花园软管。
A garden hose. That was also a hot item. Really popular. Just like practical household items that maybe you need, but you haven't been buying yourself. Well, the next Yankee swap party I have I'm actually going to include the kids because those were adult only and I want to do a family Yankee swap Okay, like an invite the kids are such at the age where they're really getting into it
花园软管。那也是个热门商品。非常受欢迎。就像实用的家居用品，也许你需要，但你一直没给自己买。好吧，我下次举办洋基交换派对时，我其实打算带上孩子们，因为以前那些是成人专场，我想办一个家庭洋基交换。好吧，就像邀请孩子们，他们正处于真正喜欢这个的年纪。
We went to one last year, but I want you to know Jennifer all the people that used to come so at the end of the night there would be these crap gifts that people would not want. And a friend of mine would unbeknownst to me hide them around my house. And I would find them months later, like, because he really hid them. Like up, like sort of on a top shelf by like the spare batteries would be like a weird porcelain clown. Yeah. You know? And Zach Woods brought this gift and he said,
我们去年去过一个，但我希望你知道，珍妮弗，所有以前常来的人，在派对结束时，会有一些人们不想要的垃圾礼物。我的一位朋友在我不知情的情况下把它们藏在我家各处。几个月后我才发现它们，因为他藏得太好了。比如，在备用电池旁边的顶层架子上，会有一个奇怪的瓷小丑。是的。你知道吗？扎克·伍兹带了这个礼物，他说，
Angela, I am the failure of Yankee Swap. Cause he brought a Egyptian. The King Tut thing. It was a King Tut miniature sarcophagus. Yeah. That opened up and you could put things inside it. And I said. I fought for that.
安吉拉，我是洋基交换的失败者。因为他带了一个埃及的东西。图坦卡蒙的东西。那是一个图坦卡蒙微型石棺。是的。可以打开，你可以把东西放进去。我说。我为那个争取过。
I thought it was really great. I loved that. Well, it got traded a bunch and he was like, I don't think anyone likes it. I was like, Zach, you're wrong. I know I'm talking a lot about my Yankee Swap party guys, but I was really inspired. Well, this is a side note about Zach Woods. You guys, he played Gabe in later seasons and he became a good friend of ours. When my son was born, he did the same thing.
我觉得它真的很棒。我喜欢那个。好吧，它被交换了很多次，他说，我不觉得有人喜欢它。我说，扎克，你错了。我知道我一直在谈论我的洋基交换派对，伙计们，但我真的很受启发。好吧，这是一个关于扎克·伍兹的旁注。伙计们，他在后几季饰演盖布，他成了我们的好朋友。我儿子出生时，他也做了同样的事。
He gave me a gift and he said, I'm so sorry. I'm not good at buying gifts for children. I don't have kids yet. I don't know. And it was this amazing astronaut costume that we still have today and use for dress up. I think he's better at buying gifts than he is. I think you are, Zach, just FYI.
他给了我一份礼物，他说，我很抱歉。我不擅长给孩子买礼物。我还没有孩子。我不知道。那是一套很棒的宇航员服装，我们今天还在用，用来装扮。我觉得他比他自己认为的更擅长买礼物。我觉得你是，扎克，顺便说一下。
All right, fast fact number two. This episode was directed by Charles McDougall. Oh guys, do we have stories about Charles McDougall? I mean, first of all, he was British. Yes. He's British. Jenna, don't do that. I'm bringing out the accent guys. I did my spin bike and now I'm speaking like a Brit. He had directed before us the HBO series Rome, which if anyone saw it, is about the Roman Empire and the killing of Julius Caesar.
好吧，第二个事实。这一集由查尔斯·麦克杜格尔执导。哦，伙计们，我们有关于查尔斯·麦克杜格尔的故事吗？我的意思是，首先，他是英国人。是的。他是英国人。珍娜，别那样。我正在模仿口音，伙计们。我骑了动感单车，现在我说话像个英国人。他在我们之前执导过HBO剧集《罗马》，如果有人看过的话，是关于罗马帝国和尤利乌斯·凯撒被杀的故事。
It is epic. It's also brutal. It's brutal. They shot in Malta. There was chariots and horses and people getting impaled. Yes. And so he went from that to our quiet little Dunder Mifflin office, a little Christmas party.
它很史诗。它也很残酷。它很残酷。他们在马耳他拍摄。有战车、马匹和被刺穿的人。是的。所以他从那部剧转到了我们安静的小邓德·米夫林办公室，一个小小的圣诞派对。
A little Christmas party. A little Christmas party. And you guys, the directors that had directed us prior to him were Ken Quapus, who might be the quietest human on the planet. Correct. He says, you know, when he wants to start a scene, he just says, uh, go ahead. And when he gives a note, he'll say, Jenna, um, you know what?
一个小小的圣诞派对。一个小小的圣诞派对。伙计们，在他之前执导我们的导演是肯·夸普斯，他可能是地球上最安静的人。没错。他说，你知道，当他想开始一个场景时，他只是说，“呃，开始吧”。当他给出建议时，他会说，珍娜，嗯，你知道吗？
No, just go ahead. Yeah. That's Ken Quapus. Yeah. You all heard Paul Feig. Paul Feig is like, hey gang, how's it going? Hey, we're going to have fun today. OK, action.
不，直接开始吧。是的，那是肯·夸普斯。是的。你们都听过保罗·费格。保罗·费格就像，嘿伙计们，怎么样？嘿，我们今天会玩得很开心。好的，开始。
Yeah. Charles McDougall rolls in. We're all sitting at our desks. Quietly. About to start the first scene. And he goes. Wait, brace yourself. Brace yourself.
是的。查尔斯·麦克杜格尔进来了。我们都坐在办公桌前。安静地。准备开始第一个场景。然后他说。等等，做好准备。做好准备。
Brace yourself. Actors, ACTION! Yes! We, I thought Phyllis peed herself a little. I, I tinkled. I tinkled. I mean, I was terrified. I jumped straight up. He was like, ADD ACTION! We were like, what's happening? What's happening? Is Tom Cruise busting through the ceiling? Any minute? I'm telling you, that first day, the first moment of every scene, we all looked like deer in headlights. We would flinch.
做好准备。演员们，开始！是的！我们，我以为菲利斯尿了一点。我，我尿了一点。我的意思是，我吓坏了。我直接跳了起来。他就像，开始！我们就像，发生了什么？发生了什么？汤姆·克鲁斯要从天花板上冲下来了吗？随时？我告诉你，第一天，每个场景的第一个瞬间，我们看起来都像受惊的鹿。我们会退缩。
We would flinch and then we would go into the scene. But then you guys, we just grew to love this guy. Oh. He would say things like, we'd be working on a scene and he'd be like, all right, you know, let's go again. Actors, nearly there. Yes. Nearly there.
我们会退缩，然后进入场景。但后来伙计们，我们开始爱上这个家伙了。哦。他会说一些话，比如我们在处理一个场景，他会说，好吧，你知道，我们再来一次。演员们，快好了。是的。快好了。
And then I- He one time said, he said, all right, everyone, that was good for cameras. Actors, better this time? Yeah. We're like, oh, okay. And then as we- We'll try to be better this time.
然后我——他有一次说，他说，好吧，大家，摄像机拍得不错。演员们，这次更好点？是的。我们就像，哦，好吧。然后当我们——我们会试着这次更好点。
As we got into the episode more and the party started, he would walk up to me and be like, Angela, remember, you're really pissed. "'You're really pissed now.'" And he sort of, and I'm gonna get into it. It's on like four or five note cards, but he sort of highlighted the level of, I called it Angela's pissed-off-ness.
随着我们进入这一集，派对开始了，他会走到我身边说，安吉拉，记住，你真的很生气。“你现在真的很生气。”他有点，我会深入讲这个。它在四五张笔记卡上，但他有点强调了那种程度，我称之为“安吉拉的愤怒”。
Yeah. And it was like building to a crescendo. And so towards the end, he would just yell before a big take in the party. He'd be like, all right, everyone happy, Angela pissed, and action. Yes. Yes.
是的。它就像在走向高潮。所以到最后，他在派对的一个大镜头前会大喊。他会说，好吧，大家开心，安吉拉生气，开始。是的。是的。
It was amazing. It was amazing. I just think it's so interesting that he went from filming all these chariots to filming people in a circle. Yeah. Sitting in a circle. What was that like for him? On desk chairs.
这太棒了。这太棒了。我只是觉得很有趣，他从拍摄所有这些战车转到了拍摄人们围成一圈。是的。坐在圆圈里。对他来说那是什么感觉？在办公椅上。
Yes. Okay. Fast fact number three. Bob Vance, Vance Refrigeration. We meet Phyllis's boyfriend. Yes, her new boyfriend. He works across the hall. He's played by Bobby Ray Schaefer. He went on to do 24 episodes of The Office, including our finale. So here's a little tidbit. Mike Schurr, our writer, said that the way that Bob Vance always introduces himself as Bob Vance, Vance Refrigeration, is based on a friend of his, actor Hayes MacArthur, who he says for years would introduce himself as Hayes MacArthur, Chicago, Illinois. Hayes MacArthur, Chicago, Illinois. Hayes MacArthur, Chicago, Illinois.
是的。好吧。第三个事实。鲍勃·万斯，万斯制冷。我们见到了菲利斯的男朋友。是的，她的新男朋友。他在走廊对面工作。他由鲍比·雷·谢弗饰演。他后来出演了24集《办公室》，包括我们的结局。所以这是一个小花絮。迈克·舒尔，我们的编剧，说鲍勃·万斯总是介绍自己为“鲍勃·万斯，万斯制冷”的方式，是基于他的一个朋友，演员海耶斯·麦克阿瑟，他说他多年来总是介绍自己为“海耶斯·麦克阿瑟，伊利诺伊州芝加哥”。海耶斯·麦克阿瑟，伊利诺伊州芝加哥。海耶斯·麦克阿瑟，伊利诺伊州芝加哥。
You guys, you might know Hayes. He would later go on to star with Rashida Jones on Angie Tribeca, which was created by Steve and Nancy Carell. Small world. Small world. But I feel comfortable sharing that story about Hayes because I know him as well and Mike said it on the DVD commentary. So he shared that with us on set, but since he put it out there,
伙计们，你们可能认识海耶斯。他后来与拉什达·琼斯一起主演了《安吉·特里贝卡》，该剧由史蒂夫和南希·卡瑞尔创作。世界真小。世界真小。但我很乐意分享关于海耶斯的故事，因为我也认识他，而且迈克在DVD评论里说过。所以他在片场和我们分享过，但既然他公开了，
I was like, well, Mike, you already said it, so I'm gonna share it here. Yeah, well, you know what? I think that some people do that. I mean, I know in my hometown, I'm from a very small town in Texas, and there are people in my town that no one ever says just their first name.
我就想，好吧，迈克，你已经说过了，所以我会在这里分享。是的，好吧，你知道吗？我觉得有些人就是那样。我的意思是，我知道在我的家乡，我来自德克萨斯州的一个非常小的城镇，在我镇上有些人从来不说他们的名字。
I don't know why, but my mom's really good friend. Her first name is Sue, and her last name is Dean, but every one in the town calls her Sue Dean. Oh, yeah. Hi, Sue Dean. How are name is Sue and her last name is Dean. But every one in the town calls her Sue Dean. Oh yeah. Hi, Sue Dean. How are you, Sue Dean? It'd be like, Jenna Fisher. How are you, Jenna Fisher? I'm good, Jenna Fisher. I mean, it's so there are some people whose names just, you just do that. Yeah. Well, we had some fans write in and ask why does he always say Bob Vance, fans of refrigeration? It was inspired by one of Mike's friends. I love it. Many people, before we go to break,
我不知道为什么，但我妈妈的好朋友。她的名字叫苏，姓迪恩，但镇上的每个人都叫她苏·迪恩。哦，是的。嗨，苏·迪恩。你好吗，苏·迪恩？就像，珍娜·费舍尔。你好吗，珍娜·费舍尔？我很好，珍娜·费舍尔。我的意思是，所以有些人就是这样。是的。好吧，我们有一些粉丝写信问为什么他总是说“鲍勃·万斯，万斯制冷”？这是受迈克的一个朋友启发。我喜欢它。很多人，在我们休息之前，
many people wrote in to tell us that Mindy's hair is down. I've maybe not received so many notes. In this episode? In this episode. No. It's down. No, it's partially up. It's partially up.
很多人写信告诉我们敏迪的头发是散着的。我可能没收到这么多笔记。在这一集里？在这一集里。不。它是散着的。不，它是部分盘起来的。它是部分盘起来的。
Oh, well, Jennifer Dinnett said that Mindy's hair is down. Jennifer Dinnett, I'm going to send you a screen grab. I mean, maybe she means down because it's not in the French twist. It's not the French twist, but she has had a few. It's half up, half down. She's had a few half up, half downs. But I would say there's more down than up. Jennifer, there's more down than up.
哦，好吧，珍妮弗·迪内特说敏迪的头发是散着的。珍妮弗·迪内特，我会给你发一张截图。我的意思是，也许她指的是散着，因为它不是法式盘发。它不是法式盘发，但她有几次。它是半盘半散。但我会说散着的时候比盘着的时候多。珍妮弗，散着的时候比盘着的时候多。
That's what she said? Well, I hope she doesn't say that. We would hope there's more down than up. That's what she said? Well, I hope she doesn't say that. Well, we would hope there's more up than down. Let's go to break. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, you often hear about like the red flags to look for in a relationship. But what if, what if we changed that focus and started making a list of the green flags that we were looking for in friends and partners? You know, more like instead of framing it,
她是这么说的？好吧，我希望她别那么说。我们希望散着的时候比盘着的时候多。她是这么说的？好吧，我希望她别那么说。好吧，我们希望盘着的时候比散着的时候多。让我们休息一下。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。你知道，你经常听到关于关系中需要注意的“危险信号”。但是如果，如果我们改变焦点，开始列出我们在朋友和伴侣身上寻找的“绿色信号”呢？你知道，与其把它框定为，
here's what I'm avoiding, be like, here's what I wanna run toward. Okay. Well, if you're not sure what your list of green flags is, therapy can help you identify them. And you know BetterHelp is fully online making therapy affordable and convenient serving over 5 million people worldwide. You can access a diverse network of more than 30,000 credentialed therapists with a wide range of specialties. You can also switch therapists at any time at no extra cost.
这是我要避免的，不如说，这是我想要追求的。好吧。如果你不确定你的绿色信号清单是什么，治疗可以帮助你识别它们。而且你知道BetterHelp完全在线，使治疗变得负担得起且方便，为全球超过500万人提供服务。你可以访问一个拥有超过30,000名持证治疗师的多样化网络，他们拥有广泛的专业领域。你也可以随时更换治疗师，无需额外费用。
Discover your relationship green flags with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's Better Help, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. Are you crushing your bills? Defeating your monthly payments. Are you crushing your bills? Defeating your monthly payments. Sounds like you're at the top of your financial game.
用BetterHelp发现你的关系绿色信号。今天就访问BetterHelp.com/officeladies，你的第一个月可享受10%的折扣。那是Better Help，H-E-L-P点com斜杠officeladies。你在努力支付账单吗？战胜你的每月付款。你在努力支付账单吗？战胜你的每月付款。听起来你处于财务游戏的顶端。
Rise to it with the BMO Eclipse Rise Visa Card. The credit card that rewards your good financial habits. Earn points for paying your credit card bill in full and on time every month. Level up from bill payer to reward slayer. Terms and conditions apply. When you sit on your aeroplan points, it's like you're sitting on your next trip. Like a sunny getaway sitting on a terrace. But instead you're sitting on your aeroplan points. So the only place you're sitting is in your car coming back from work.
用BMO Eclipse Rise Visa卡提升自己。这张信用卡奖励你的良好财务习惯。每月全额准时支付信用卡账单即可赚取积分。从账单支付者升级为奖励赢家。条款和条件适用。当你坐在你的Aeroplan积分上时，就像你坐在你的下一次旅行上一样。就像坐在露台上的阳光度假。但相反，你坐在你的Aeroplan积分上。所以你唯一坐的地方就是下班回家的车里。
Use your points and go from sipping on your leftover latte to sipping on the local vintage. So stop sitting on your next trip and start enjoying your Aeroplan points. All right, so let's dive in here. We've got the cold open. In the very first few seconds, Pam is stuffing the Christmas envelopes, the Christmas photo. Yeah. Right? She's doing the Christmas card mass mailing. The Christmas card. I did this at 1-800-DENTIST. Oh, you did the 1-800-DENTIST company Christmas card mailing?
使用你的积分，从啜饮剩下的拿铁变成啜饮当地的陈年佳酿。所以别再坐在你的下一次旅行上，开始享受你的Aeroplan积分吧。好吧，让我们深入探讨一下。我们有冷开场。在最初的几秒钟里，帕姆正在装圣诞信封，圣诞照片。是的。对吧？她正在进行圣诞贺卡的大规模邮寄。圣诞贺卡。我在1-800-DENTIST做过这个。哦，你做了1-800-DENTIST公司的圣诞贺卡邮寄？
I did. I volunteered and you got to hop off the phone so you didn't have to talk to people about like their rotten teeth. Yeah. And I would go in the mail room and they'd be playing Christmas music and I'd have a cup of tea and I would just stuff envelopes all day and I was so happy. Oh yeah. I did many, many mass mailings as an administrative assistant.
我做了。我自愿参加，这样你就可以不用接电话，不用和人们谈论他们腐烂的牙齿。是的。我会去收发室，他们会播放圣诞音乐，我会喝杯茶，整天装信封，我非常开心。哦，是的。作为行政助理，我做了很多很多大规模邮寄。
I'd have to bind things, copy on both sides, collate, bind and mail. I'm very happy doing those things. Okay, but the photo was our cast photo that we took our Christmas photo. It was not our Christmas photo. What? Oh yeah, it was. Listen, I maybe got a little too obsessed with it, but I thought I recognized it. I screen-wrapped it. It was me too. It's our season one publicity photo from the pilot. You're right. Cause I'm sitting in the front.
我得装订东西，双面复印，整理，装订和邮寄。做这些事情我非常开心。好吧，但那张照片是我们演员的照片，我们拍的圣诞照片。那不是我们的圣诞照片。什么？哦，是的，它是。听着，我可能有点太痴迷于它了，但我以为我认出来了。我截屏了。那也是我。那是我们第一季试播集的宣传照。你是对的。因为我坐在前面。
Oh my gosh. And we're not wearing any Christmas stuff. Oh, Jenna, good catch. I totally just thought it was our Christmas picture. Well, we had a fan question from Pizookie. Did anyone keep a copy of the holiday card Pam is stuffing into the envelopes at the beginning? Well, I don't have a copy of the holiday card Pam is stuffing into the envelopes at the beginning. Well, I don't have a copy of the card, but I have a copy of that picture hanging in my office.
天哪。而且我们没穿任何圣诞服装。哦，珍娜，好眼力。我完全以为那是我们的圣诞照片。好吧，我们收到了Pizookie的一个粉丝提问。有人保留了帕姆在开头装进信封里的那张节日贺卡吗？好吧，我没有那张贺卡的副本，但我办公室里挂着那张照片的副本。
And I examined it against the card that Pam is putting into the envelopes. Well, remember in the pilot. Who's my detective? Henriette. Thank you so much, CSI office ladies. Henriette is in that photo. Henriette is in the photo on my wall because she was in the pilot. They photoshopped Kate's head onto Henriette's body
我把它和帕姆放进信封里的那张卡片进行了对比。好吧，记得在试播集里。谁是我的侦探？亨丽埃特。非常感谢，CSI办公室女士。亨丽埃特在那张照片里。亨丽埃特在我墙上的照片里，因为她在试播集里。他们把凯特的头P到了亨丽埃特的身体上
for the picture I'm stuffing into the envelope in this episode. I really want that card. Dang it. Yeah, because I can see it's Henriette's hand on her hip in the sweater that's hanging in my office, but Kate's face. Way to go, Jenna. So far we've covered one second of the episode that happens in the first one to three seconds. The next thing that happens is that Michael and Dwight enter with the tree and it's really way too big. It's way too big. It goes through the ceiling. I feel like this is a
为了我在这一集里装进信封的那张照片。我真的很想要那张卡片。该死。是的，因为我可以看到我办公室里挂着的那件毛衣里，亨丽埃特的手叉在腰上，但脸是凯特的。干得好，珍娜。到目前为止，我们涵盖了这一集发生在前一到三秒钟的一秒钟。接下来发生的事情是迈克尔和德怀特带着树进来了，它真的太大了。它太大了。它穿过了天花板。我觉得这是对
little nod to Christmas Vacation. Yes. You know, with Chevy Chase and that enormous tree. Yes. Well, do you remember when we were on set, about three or four times when they pushed it up, the ceiling towel actually fell down and would fall on Steve's head. And then they'd have to brush him off with a little brush and fix his hair. There was little pieces of white sort of like particle looking stuff all over the ground because the ceiling kept busting apart. I loved that Kevin cuts the top of the Christmas tree with a paper trimmer.
《疯狂圣诞假期》的一点致敬。是的。你知道，切维·切斯和那棵巨大的树。是的。好吧，你记得我们在片场时，他们推它的时候，天花板瓷砖实际上掉了下来，掉在史蒂夫的头上，大约有三四次。然后他们不得不拿小刷子帮他刷掉，整理他的头发。地上到处都是白色的小颗粒状的东西，因为天花板一直在破碎。我喜欢凯文用纸张切割机切掉圣诞树顶部。
I just thought that was such a nice touch. Well, it makes sense. It's what we'd have. It's what we would have. Yeah. Okay. I did kind of an Angela thing. What's that?
我只是觉得那是一个很好的细节。好吧，这说得通。这是我们会有的。这是我们会有的。是的。好吧，我做了一件安吉拉式的事情。那是什么？
Did you drink rosé during the day? I did not, but I did. I wrote down everybody's Christmas outfits. I love this. So did I. You did? Okay, let's do it. Okay. All right. I noticed that Michael has a Christmas tie. Yes, he does. It has a Santa on it and some snowmen. Go. Christmas tie, Kevin.
你白天喝桃红葡萄酒了吗？我没有，但我做了。我写下了每个人的圣诞服装。我喜欢这个。我也是。你做了？好吧，我们开始吧。好吧。我注意到迈克尔有一条圣诞领带。是的，他有。上面有一个圣诞老人和一些雪人。开始。圣诞领带，凯文。
Yes, snowman, wintery scene. All right. You and I both only have a Christmas pin and Christmas earrings. You have Christmas ornament earrings. I have Christmas stocking earrings, and we both have a version of a Santa Claus pin. Interesting. We're dressed kind of similar. Very similarly. What's that about?
是的，雪人，冬日场景。好吧。你和我只有一枚圣诞胸针和圣诞耳环。你有圣诞装饰耳环。我有圣诞袜耳环，我们都有一个圣诞老人胸针的版本。有趣。我们穿得有点像。非常相似。那是怎么回事？
I don't know, but Phyllis has a full Christmas blouse and vest. I love her Christmas vest. My sister's a school teacher and she does that. Like at Christmas time, she wears all these Christmas sweaters and vests. You know I love this stuff. I've got all of it. My mom back in St. Louis, Missouri, every year she goes to the local art fairs and craft fairs and she sends me Christmas hoodies, Christmas vests, Christmas pajamas, Christmas everything. I mean, those earrings could have been yours because you've come to my house at Christmas
我不知道，但菲利斯有一件完整的圣诞衬衫和背心。我喜欢她的圣诞背心。我姐姐是学校老师，她也那样。比如在圣诞节期间，她穿所有这些圣诞毛衣和背心。你知道我喜欢这些东西。我都有。我妈妈在密苏里州圣路易斯，每年她都会去当地的艺术博览会和手工艺博览会，她会寄给我圣诞连帽衫、圣诞背心、圣诞睡衣，圣诞一切。我的意思是，那些耳环本可以是你的，因为你圣诞节来我家时
and you always have on Christmas jewelry. I'll tell you right now, I would never show up at a Christmas party and only Christmas earrings and Christmas pin. I know. I mean, that is, I know. I go all out. You go all out. Oh, Oscar has a Christmas tie.
你总是戴着圣诞首饰。我现在就告诉你，我绝不会只戴圣诞耳环和圣诞胸针去参加圣诞派对。我知道。我的意思是，那是，我知道。我全力以赴。你全力以赴。哦，奥斯卡有一条圣诞领带。
Oscar has a Christmas tie. Stanley has a red tie. So I guess that's his, his attempt. Very Stanley. That's as far as he would go. I, I'm actually surprised he went that far. No. For Stanley. I know. Also, Meredith has a crazy Christmas sweater. Yeah. See, if it were me, I would be Meredith or Phyllis showing up to your party. Full, full, full outfit. I know. I've seen how you come to my party. I love it. All right, so in this scene that's coming up,
奥斯卡有一条圣诞领带。斯坦利有一条红领带。所以我猜那是他的，他的尝试。非常斯坦利。那是他能做到的极限。我，我其实很惊讶他做到了那一步。不。对于斯坦利。我知道。还有，梅雷迪思有一件疯狂的圣诞毛衣。是的。看，如果是我，我会像梅雷迪思或菲利斯一样出现在你的派对上。完整，完整，完整的服装。我知道。我见过你是怎么来我的派对的。我喜欢它。好吧，所以在接下来的这个场景里，
Jim reveals that he got Pam in Secret Santa. He does, can I, listen, Jim fans, you're probably not gonna like me for saying this, but at two minutes, two seconds, in his talking head, he says he wants, you know, he got Pam for Secret Santa and he said because Pam wants a teapot so she can make tea at her desk. Yeah.
吉姆透露他抽到了帕姆作为秘密圣诞老人。他确实，我可以，听着，吉姆的粉丝们，你们可能不会因为我这么说而喜欢我，但在两分零二秒，在他的谈话片段里，他说他想要，你知道，他抽到了帕姆作为秘密圣诞老人，他说因为帕姆想要一个茶壶，这样她就可以在办公桌上泡茶。是的。
And I wrote WTF, who makes tea at their desk? She would go in the kitchen. What is she gonna do? Go to the kitchen, put the hot water in the teapot, carry it back to her desk, pour herself a cup of tea at her desk. She's gonna carry that teapot from the kitchen. What part of this is confusing you?
我写了“WTF”，谁在办公桌上泡茶？她会去厨房。她要干什么？去厨房，把热水放进茶壶里，带回办公桌，在办公桌上给自己倒一杯茶。她要从厨房带那个茶壶过来。这部分的哪一点让你困惑？
I think it's ridiculous. Okay, here's her other option, okay? She goes into the kitchen. Oh, I see the breakdown. I see how your brain is tracking it and why it doesn't make sense. And also because I know you and you just put the teabag right into the cup,
我觉得这很荒谬。好吧，这是她的另一个选择，好吧？她去厨房。哦，我明白了解析。我明白了你的大脑是如何追踪它的，以及为什么它说不通。而且因为我了解你，你只是把茶包直接放进杯子里，
which is a totally acceptable way to make a Let it seep Steep steep With a tea let it seep on in there you leave it in your pot That's right. I said that the scene could be called something else. What could it be called instead of what's inside the teapot? It could be called Jim else. What could it be called? Instead of what's inside the teapot, it could be called, Jim's got it bad. Oh. Because he saved two sauce packets from a few years ago.
这是一种完全可以接受的泡茶方式。让它浸泡。浸泡。浸泡。用茶让它浸泡在那里。你把它留在你的壶里。没错。我说过那个场景可以叫别的名字。它还可以叫什么，而不是“茶壶里有什么”？它可以叫“吉姆惨了”。哦。因为他留下了几年前的两包酱汁。
Yeah. That's someone who has got it really bad. Yeah. Yeah, I feel like that could have been written a little differently, where Jim could have said, a couple of years ago, Pam did this thing with the hot sauce and therefore I am putting a packet of hot sauce in there. The fact that he saved the two packets of hot sauce. For years.
是的。那是一个真的很惨的人。是的。是的，我觉得那可以写得稍微不同一点，吉姆可以说，几年前，帕姆用辣酱做了这件事，因此我把一包辣酱放在里面。他留下了两包辣酱的事实。多年。
For years. Yeah. He loves you. He loves you. Okay, go on. He definitely does. All right. Well, I do have a lot to say about the teapot.
多年。是的。他爱你。他爱你。好吧，继续。他绝对是。好吧。嗯，关于茶壶我确实有很多话要说。
So first of all, Phil Shea offered me a variety of teapots before we started shooting in many colors and I picked the teal. I love it. Yeah, I don't know. Little pop of color. The writers also said that picking what this gift would be, the fact that it would be a teapot, provided a major challenge because they needed a gift that could hide other gifts, that was really personal, and that would be very stressful when Dwight takes it away from Pam.
首先，在拍摄开始前，菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）为我提供了各种颜色的茶壶，我选了蓝绿色。我很喜欢。嗯，我不知道，就是一点亮色。编剧们也说，选择这个礼物本身——也就是茶壶——是一个巨大的挑战，因为他们需要一个能藏住其他礼物的礼物，它必须非常私人化，而且当德怀特（Dwight）从帕姆（Pam）手中抢走它时，会让人感到非常紧张。
It could only cost $20, and it had to be something that Dwight really wanted. And they said it was not easy. They spent a very long time because they knew plot-wise had to happen that Jim gives Pam a gift filled with secret treasures that Dwight also wants to have that costs under $20. It took them a very long time to come up with teapot. For that reason alone, okay, fine. Pam can make her tea at the counter. She can stick some tea at her desk. Because when Dwight puts it in his nose, I know that's later, but it's so perfect.
它只能价值20美元，而且必须是德怀特真正想要的东西。他们说这并不容易。他们花了很多时间，因为他们知道剧情上必须发生这样的事：吉姆（Jim）送给帕姆一个装满秘密宝藏的茶壶，而德怀特也想要这个价值不到20美元的礼物。他们花了很长时间才想到茶壶。仅凭这一点，好吧，没问题。帕姆可以在柜台上泡茶。她可以在办公桌上放些茶包。因为当德怀特把它凑到鼻子前时——我知道那是后面的情节了——但那真的太完美了。
It is. It's so perfect. It is. It's so perfect. I mean, they nailed it, right? They nailed it. And now this teapot is famous. I mean, all the time, people are using this teapot idea to propose to their loved ones.
确实。太完美了。没错。太完美了。我是说，他们做到了，对吧？他们做到了。现在这个茶壶出名了。我是说，人们一直都在用这个茶壶的点子向爱人求婚。
I see it all the time in my Instagram. People are tagging me. It's always charming to me. It's always so sweet. It is very thoughtful. So we mentioned the things that he's putting into the teapot. Here's a fan question. Taylor Rilling said, what is the significance of the pencil that Jim puts in the teapot? Yeah, he said that the story is too long.
我在Instagram上经常看到。人们会标记我。这对我来说总是很迷人。总是那么甜蜜。这确实非常贴心。我们提到了他放进茶壶里的东西。这里有个粉丝提问。泰勒·里林（Taylor Rilling）问，吉姆放进茶壶里的那支铅笔有什么意义？嗯，他说那个故事太长了。
So we have a deleted scene. And I remember shooting it. What Pam says when she picks up the pencil is she says, Oh my gosh, this is the pencil I threw at you during mini golf. What? When did Jim and Pam go play mini golf? Maybe the whole office went and played mini golf. That seems like something Michael Scott would be like, we're going to play mini golf
我们有一个删减片段。我记得当时拍摄的情景。帕姆拿起铅笔时说：“天哪，这就是我在迷你高尔夫球场扔给你的那支铅笔。”什么？吉姆和帕姆什么时候去打过迷你高尔夫？也许整个办公室的人都去打过迷你高尔夫。这听起来像是迈克尔·斯科特（Michael Scott）会做的事，他会说：“我们要去打迷你高尔夫。”
and we're gonna raise money for my neighbors. Like whatever. That's all I can think of is that there was some office outing where they went and played mini golf and I guess Pam got all feisty and threw a pencil at him and he saved it. So that's where the pencil is. And then of course he puts a card in the box and he says, because Christmas time is the time to tell people how you feel. Oh yeah, that's so loaded.
“我们要为我的邻居筹款。”之类的。我能想到的就是有一次办公室郊游，他们去打了迷你高尔夫，我猜帕姆当时很兴奋，朝他扔了一支铅笔，而他把它留下了。所以铅笔就是这么来的。然后当然，他在盒子里放了一张卡片，他说，因为圣诞节是告诉人们你真实感受的时候。哦，是的，这太有深意了。
I have PPC next. Let's hit some PPC, the Party Planning Committee. You know, Mike Schur also wrote the PPC in the Alliance. I think he likes the PPC. Oh, he definitely likes the PPC and their weird sort of power struggle. He loves it. Well, in this scene, we find out that Ryan has been drafted into the PPC. I can't believe that.
接下来是PPC。让我们聊聊PPC，即派对策划委员会（Party Planning Committee）。你知道，迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur）也写了《联盟》（The Alliance）那一集里的PPC。我觉得他喜欢PPC。哦，他绝对喜欢PPC以及他们那种奇怪的权力斗争。他很喜欢。嗯，在这一幕中，我们发现瑞安（Ryan）被征召进了PPC。我简直不敢相信。
I remember that. I can't believe that Angela Martin would recruit him except that maybe she needed help, like someone setting up things and moving things. Well, the Christmas party is a big one. It's a big one. Yeah. Yeah. But also I noticed that Meredith is in there. Yeah.
我记得那个。我不敢相信安吉拉·马丁（Angela Martin）会招募他，除非她需要帮手，比如有人帮忙布置和搬运东西。嗯，圣诞派对是个大工程。确实很大。是的。但我也注意到梅雷迪思（Meredith）也在里面。是的。
No, it's all hands on deck. She probably has a bigger crew than just her core crew. Well, that's when Michael enters in his Santa beard. He throws down some cash because he wants a bigger, better party. And he reveals he has a digital camera and he will be taking photos. Yeah. And he's going to put them in the newsletter. Most embarrassing one wins. Yes.
不，这是全员出动。她可能有一个比核心团队更大的团队。嗯，就在这时，迈克尔戴着圣诞老人胡子进来了。他扔下了一些现金，因为他想要一个更大、更好的派对。他还透露他有一台数码相机，他会拍照。是的。他要把照片放进通讯里。最尴尬的一张获胜。是的。
I want you guys to know, when Steve came behind Phyllis and I, and he was like, I want people making out, and he shoved her heads together and was like, blah, blah, blah. That was an improv. That was improv. Yeah.
我想让你们知道，当史蒂夫（Steve）走到菲利斯（Phyllis）和我身后时，他说：“我想要人们亲热，”然后他把他们的头推在一起，说着“吧啦吧啦吧啦”。那是即兴表演。那是即兴的。是的。
Phyllis and I didn't know that was coming. He just did it in the moment. I was really proud that neither of us started laughing. I'm proud. I was so proud of myself because there were a few times in that scene I almost broke and I was really fighting it. Oh, it's also in this scene, Angela, that it's revealed that Phyllis was in charge of getting the lights for the Christmas tree.
菲利斯和我当时都不知道会发生这种事。他只是在那个瞬间即兴发挥的。我真的很自豪，我们俩都没有笑场。我很自豪。我为自己感到骄傲，因为在那一幕中我有几次差点破功，我真的在努力克制。哦，也是在这一幕中，安吉拉，揭露了菲利斯负责为圣诞树买灯。
And she said she got the little ones. Yeah. And you have a reaction to that? Well, that's not going to go over well later. That is not going to go over. So like I said, I listened to the DVD commentary of this. And Mike was really good on the commentary at breaking down some of his goals for the episode. And his goal for the episode was that Angela would get more and more and more stressed out every scene
她说她买了那种小灯。是的。你对此有什么反应吗？嗯，这之后可不会有好结果。这绝对行不通。所以就像我说的，我听了这一集的DVD评论音轨。迈克在评论中非常出色地剖析了他对这一集的一些目标。他这一集的目标是让安吉拉在每一幕中都变得越来越紧张。
that we see her. And I think you can track that. As I was watching it again, I can totally see that. I have five note cards called Angela's Pissed Offness. Yes. That I'm going to start with timecode soon. Before we get into all that, I do have to point out because I was texting with Kim Ferry, who did my hair for nine years on The Office last night. This is the Angela hair braid. That is my actual hair that she had me bend over and braid. And of course my character would want to wear it to the Christmas party. I
我们能看出来。当我再次观看时，我完全能看出来。我有五张笔记卡，上面写着“安吉拉的愤怒程度”。是的。我很快就会开始按时间码来记录。在我们进入这些之前，我必须指出，因为我昨晚和金·费里（Kim Ferry）发了短信，她在《办公室》里为我做了九年的发型。这就是安吉拉的编发。那是我的真发，她让我弯下腰编的。当然，我的角色会想在圣诞派对上戴着它。我
feel like this was her special braid. For special occasions. For special occasions. And while we're talking PPC guys, I have to say Pam would probably irk me too on this committee. What? I mean, at four minutes, 25 seconds, Angela is trying to put a tablecloth on this table. Pam is just staring at her, doing nothing,
觉得这是她特别的编发。为了特殊场合。为了特殊场合。当我们谈论PPC时，我不得不说，帕姆在这个委员会里可能也会让我感到烦躁。什么？我是说，在4分25秒时，安吉拉正试图在桌子上铺桌布。帕姆只是盯着她看，什么也不做，
not trying to grab for the tablecloth, help her spread it out, anything. And Angela just looks at her and is just like, will you help me? When I saw that scene, I found it so satisfying. It's her little bit of defiance against your just... Crazy controlling. Yes, yes, just your everything that's coming at her.
没有试图去抓桌布，帮她铺开，什么都没有。安吉拉只是看着她，就像是说：“你能帮我吗？”当我看到那一幕时，我觉得非常满足。这是她对你那种……疯狂控制欲的一点点反抗。是的，是的，就是你对她所做的一切。
And you know, I told you, I go back and I read my journals and I had written, and I also have these old blogs and I had written in one of my old blogs that filming the scene where I don't help you put the tablecloth on was one of my favorites of the whole episode. It's such like passive aggressive defiance. I loved it. I loved it. Well, Jenna, I went and found my MySpace blogs.
你知道，我告诉过你，我回去读了我的日记，我写过，而且我还有这些旧博客，我在其中一个旧博客里写道，拍摄我不帮你铺桌布的那一幕是我整集里最喜欢的场景之一。这是一种被动攻击式的反抗。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。嗯，珍娜（Jenna），我回去找了我的MySpace博客。
So they're not online anymore. I don't know why, but I so but I guess I had printed them out at some point. Smart. So now I'm going to start going to them for each episode. And I did for this one, but I'll save it for a bit because it happens later in the episode. Okay, great. Fan question from small actor in a Peacoat. Who kept the camera with all of the pictures that Michael took? NBC. Yeah, they were property of NBC and they had them up on their website for a while. But guess what? You can still find them. Jenna and I were texting last night. We both found
它们已经不在网上了。我不知道为什么，但我猜我在某个时候把它们打印出来了。聪明。所以现在我打算在每一集里都参考它们。这一集我也看了，但我会先留着不说，因为它发生在这一集的后面。好的，太棒了。来自“穿豌豆大衣的小演员”的粉丝提问。是谁保留了迈克尔拍的所有照片的相机？NBC。是的，它们是NBC的财产，他们在网站上放了一段时间。但你猜怎么着？你仍然可以找到它们。珍娜和我昨晚发短信。我们都找到了
them over at OfficeTally.com. Yeah. So you can see all those pictures that he was really taking pictures. Yeah. And they're really like not centered and like people's heads are cut off. It's as if he just went around clicking away, but there's some real gems in there. I know. Six minutes, 54 seconds. Michael really, really shows what he thinks about Christmas, which is a gift should say, I love you this many dollars worth.
它们在OfficeTally.com上。是的。所以你可以看到所有那些照片，他确实是在拍照。是的。而且它们真的拍得没对准，比如人们的头被切掉了。就好像他只是到处乱拍，但里面确实有一些真正的珍品。我知道。6分54秒。迈克尔真的，真的展示了他对圣诞节的看法，那就是礼物应该表达：“我爱你，价值这么多钱。”
Yeah. Oh, this is you this many dollars worth. Yeah. Oh, this is not gonna go well. Well, speaking of gifts, we have a scene where Toby reveals what he got Angela in Secret Santa. And it is the jazz baby poster. Yeah. I have that poster, guys.
是的。哦，这是“我爱你，价值这么多钱”。是的。哦，这可不会有好结果。嗯，说到礼物，我们有一个场景，托比（Toby）透露了他给安吉拉准备的秘密圣诞礼物。那是爵士宝贝海报。是的。我有那张海报，伙计们。
You have it? That was one of my questions from Chris Cordova. He wants to know, did you keep the baby poster? Well, there was about 20 of them. They had made a bunch. One hung by my desk for years. Yes. Yeah.
你有？那是克里斯·科尔多瓦（Chris Cordova）问我的问题之一。他想知道，你留着那张婴儿海报吗？嗯，大约有20张。他们做了一堆。有一张在我桌子旁挂了好几年。是的。是的。
So we got to see it every day. And I have one. It's rolled up in a little poster thingy. Now, do you know the story behind that picture? Because I traded some text messages with Phil Shea. So Phil Shea had to make that poster. He did not buy that poster. He put out a casting call for babies.
所以我们每天都能看到它。我有一张。它卷在一个小海报筒里。现在，你知道那张照片背后的故事吗？因为我和菲尔·谢伊交换了一些短信。所以菲尔·谢伊必须制作那张海报。他不是买的。他发布了一个婴儿选角通告。
And two babies were cast, baby actors. He said it was really hard to find tiny jazz instruments. He said that was really difficult. In fact, he said, you know, Amazon didn't exist back then. You know, you couldn't just Google baby jazz instrument. And they couldn't be fake looking, like they couldn't be like blue and pink. So he did eventually find them at a place called Hollywood Costumes. He was particularly proud of the tiny sunglasses that he found. This poster ends up coming back in conflict resolution. Like you said, it stayed up
选了两个婴儿，婴儿演员。他说很难找到微型爵士乐器。他说那真的很难。事实上，他说，你知道，那时候亚马逊还不存在。你知道，你不能直接谷歌搜索“婴儿爵士乐器”。而且它们不能看起来是假的，比如不能是蓝色和粉色的。所以他最终在一家叫“好莱坞服装”（Hollywood Costumes）的地方找到了它们。他对自己找到的微型太阳镜感到特别自豪。这张海报最终在《冲突解决》（Conflict Resolution）一集中又出现了。就像你说的，它一直挂
there but then it comes back again. It comes back again. I would like to know the two babies that were in the poster. Oh guys! Where are they today? One thing about that baby jazz poster, I remember Mike Schur telling me that they thought it was really funny that Angela would really enjoy babies dressed as adults. Okay, where are we? Well, we're talking about the gifts. And Mike Schur actually said that the gifts were incredibly hard to manage because they
在那里，但后来又出现了。它又出现了。我想知道海报里的那两个婴儿是谁。哦，伙计们！他们今天在哪里？关于那张婴儿爵士海报，我记得迈克·舒尔告诉我，他们认为安吉拉会非常喜欢打扮成大人的婴儿，这真的很有趣。好了，我们聊到哪了？嗯，我们在谈论礼物。迈克·舒尔实际上说，这些礼物非常难管理，因为它们
start off as Secret Santa. So everybody had a person that they bought a specific gift for, and then you had to track the gifts as they went around in the Yankee swap. He actually, in the script of this episode, there is a whole page where he lists the gifts. Who bought who what? And he did this for Veda, our script supervisor. We haven't really talked about her, but Veda's job is to sit and watch every take that is filmed and make notes about everything that happens continuity wise. So I mean, like really specific.
一开始是秘密圣诞老人。所以每个人都有一个他们专门买礼物的对象，然后你必须追踪这些礼物在“洋基交换”（Yankee Swap）中是如何流转的。实际上，在这一集的剧本里，有一整页他列出了礼物。谁买了什么给谁？他为我们的剧本主管维达（Veda）做了这件事。我们还没怎么谈过她，但维达的工作是坐着观看拍摄的每一个镜头，并记录下所有关于连续性的事情。所以我是说，非常具体。
So like, if in a scene you take a drink of your tea on a certain line and then scratch your nose on another one, Veda writes it down so that you do it the same every time for editing purposes. Yeah, or Veda would come up to us and say, Angela, you were holding that pen in your left hand in the first take. And in the second take, you picked it up and held it in your right hand.
比如，如果在一个场景中，你在某句台词时喝了一口茶，然后在另一句台词时抓了抓鼻子，维达会记下来，这样你在编辑时每次都能做得一样。是的，或者维达会走到我们面前说：“安吉拉，你在第一个镜头里用左手拿着那支笔。在第二个镜头里，你把它拿起来换到了右手。”
So that's not going to match. So you need to pick which hand you're going to hold that pen in and do it in every take the same way. Yeah, because otherwise, when you edit it together, the pen is magically bouncing from hand to hand. So Mike was really worried about VEDA in this episode. And so he made this list just for VEDA. And I have it from the script.
“所以这不连贯。你需要选定用哪只手拿笔，并且在每个镜头里都这样做。”是的，因为否则，当你把它们剪辑在一起时，笔会神奇地在两只手之间跳来跳去。所以迈克在这一集里非常担心维达。所以他专门为维达做了这个清单。我从剧本里拿到了。
Oh, fantastic. OK, so this is what everyone was intended to give. And we got a lot of fan questions about this. Like, a lot of people wrote in and said, you know, eventually Michael's going to get the paintball lessons from Dwight, but they're like, who did Dwight intend that to go to? So I have all the answers right here. Are you ready? Yeah. Okay. Dwight got Phyllis the paintball lessons and the pellets. That was his gift to Phyllis. Phyllis made Michael an oven mitt. Michael got Ryan an iPod.
哦，太棒了。好的，这就是每个人原本打算送的礼物。我们收到了很多关于这个的粉丝提问。比如，很多人写信说，你知道，迈克尔最终会从德怀特那里得到彩弹射击课程，但他们问，德怀特原本打算把那个送给谁？所以我这里有所有答案。准备好了吗？是的。好的。德怀特给菲利斯准备了彩弹射击课程和弹丸。那是他给菲利斯的礼物。菲利斯给迈克尔做了一个烤箱手套。迈克尔给瑞安买了一个iPod。
Ryan got Toby a book of short stories by George Saunders, who happens to be one of Mike Schur's favorite writers. Toby got Angela the baby poster. Angela bought Stanley a picture frame. Stanley got Kelly a nameplate. Kelly got Oscar a shower radio. Oscar got Creed a shamrock keychain. Creed got Jim one of his own shirts. Jim got Pam the teapot. And this is something that got cut out. Pam made Meredith
瑞安给托比买了一本乔治·桑德斯（George Saunders）的短篇小说集，他恰好是迈克·舒尔最喜欢的作家之一。托比给安吉拉买了婴儿海报。安吉拉给斯坦利（Stanley）买了一个相框。斯坦利给凯利（Kelly）买了一个名牌。凯利给奥斯卡（Oscar）买了一个淋浴收音机。奥斯卡给克里德（Creed）买了一个三叶草钥匙扣。克里德给吉姆买了他自己的一件衬衫。吉姆给帕姆买了茶壶。这是被剪掉的部分。帕姆给梅雷迪思
a drawing of the office. I read about that online. Yeah. And there was this big thing. It's in the deleted scenes. This is something I have to tell you. I got a DVD player for Christmas. What? My husband got me a DVD player. So I got the CDs. He bought me the CD set and I got a DVD player. And last night I got to watch all the deleted scenes. Oh, Angela, you must be so happy. I was so happy. And there's so many. Oh, yeah. There's so many for the Christmas episode, you guys. There are so many great deleted scenes. I don't want to get us off topic here, but they're in the deleted scenes. Meredith opens up her painting.
画了一幅办公室的画。我在网上读到过。是的。而且有一件大事。它在删减片段里。这是我必须告诉你的。我圣诞节收到了一台DVD播放机。什么？我丈夫给我买了一台DVD播放机。所以我有了CD。他给我买了CD套装，我还得到了一台DVD播放机。昨晚我看了所有的删减片段。哦，安吉拉，你一定很高兴。我太高兴了。而且有很多。哦，是的，圣诞那一集有很多，伙计们。有很多很棒的删减片段。我不想让我们偏离主题，但它们在删减片段里。梅雷迪思打开了她的画。
That is from Pam, and it's a drawing of the office. Well, there's a big backstory here, again, with Phil. I don't do Pam's drawings. People ask me that all the time. I am not an artist. I mean, we've talked about this or have we that I do cartoons, I do cartooning. She's very good at cartooning
那是帕姆送的，是一幅办公室的画。嗯，这里又有一个关于菲尔的大背景故事。我不画帕姆的画。人们总是问我这个问题。我不是艺术家。我是说，我们谈过这个，或者我们谈过我画卡通吗？我做卡通画。她非常擅长画卡通。
and I have a few that you've drawn that I've saved. I think you're fantastic. Well, I love my little expressive cartoons, but I needed Pam and wanted Pam to be a better artist than I am. So there is a young art student that does all of Pam's drawings. They went out to a bunch of people, like 12 different artists, to turn in samples, to be the artist behind Pam, and they picked a young woman.
我保存了几张你画的。我觉得你太棒了。嗯，我喜欢我那些富有表现力的小卡通，但我需要帕姆，也希望帕姆是一个比我更好的艺术家。所以有一个年轻的艺术系学生负责帕姆所有的画。他们找了一群人，大约12个不同的艺术家，提交样本，成为帕姆背后的艺术家，他们选了一个年轻女性。
SONIA DARA Now, Jenna, I read, and you can tell me if this is true, I read that the first painting that they had for this episode to give to Meredith from Pam, that they had one of our set art people, who was a man, do it. And when they looked at it, it looked too masculine. And so then they went out to female artists to have a little bit of a softer touch. Yeah. And there were something like 12 different artists who all submitted their work. And I wish I knew her name. Unfortunately, I don't.
索尼娅·达拉（SONIA DARA）。现在，珍娜，我读到过，你可以告诉我这是不是真的，我读到过，他们为这一集准备的给梅雷迪思的第一幅画，是让我们的一个布景艺术人员，一个男人，画的。当他们看的时候，看起来太阳刚了。所以他们就去找女性艺术家，想要一种更柔和的感觉。是的。大约有12个不同的艺术家提交了作品。我真希望我知道她的名字。不幸的是，我不知道。
But maybe I can find that out and reveal that in a future episode. And then so finally, two more gifts. Meredith got Dwight some shot glasses from Cancun, and Kevin got himself a foot bath. Guys, around five minutes, 55 seconds, there is a scene where Michael is talking to Jim at Jim's desk. This is when he reveals that he got Ryan for Secret Santa.
但也许我以后能查到并在未来的某一集里揭晓。最后，还有两个礼物。梅雷迪思给德怀特买了一些坎昆的烈酒杯，凯文给自己买了一个足浴盆。伙计们，在5分55秒左右，有一个场景是迈克尔在吉姆的办公桌前和吉姆说话。这是他透露他抽到了瑞安作为秘密圣诞老人的时候。
And I just want to say you see a ton of background action. Angela, you're walking from reception. Over Steve's shoulder, you see Toby and Mindy talking. They are 100% not in character. Not in character at all. I saw that too. I was like, they're just talking about probably something in the writer's room or a story pitch
我只想说，你可以看到大量的背景动作。安吉拉，你正从接待处走过来。在史蒂夫的肩膀后面，你可以看到托比和敏迪（Mindy）在说话。他们100%没有进入角色。完全没有进入角色。我也看到了。我想，他们可能只是在谈论编剧室里的某件事或者一个故事构思，
or they're just having a conversation. Yeah, I mean, Paul is just being Paul. Yeah. If anyone's curious, the difference between Toby and Paul, go to five minutes, 55 seconds, and you can see Paul and Mindy having a conversation in the background. Yeah, exactly.
或者他们只是在聊天。是的，我是说，保罗（Paul）只是在做保罗自己。是的。如果有人好奇托比和保罗的区别，去看看5分55秒，你可以看到保罗和敏迪在背景里聊天。是的，没错。
Tree lighting. Okay, I've been waiting for this moment. The Christmas tree lighting. This starts the beginning of everyone happy, Angela pissed. So, so this Christmas tree, the top of it has been hacked off by Kevin. It is covered in so much tinsel. Yeah.
点亮圣诞树。好的，我一直在等这一刻。圣诞树点灯。这标志着每个人都很开心，安吉拉很生气的开始。所以，这棵圣诞树，它的顶部被凯文砍掉了。上面覆盖了太多的金属丝。是的。
So much tinsel. It has a smattering of just blue and red ball ornaments. It's just not their best effort. And then it has the tiniest of tiny white lights thanks to Phyllis. So Dwight makes a big deal of it. He like takes the, like the outlet, like the plug. What do you call it?
太多的金属丝。上面零星地点缀着蓝色和红色的球形装饰品。这真的不是他们最好的努力。然后它有最细小的白色小灯，多亏了菲利斯。所以德怀特对此大做文章。他拿那个，比如插座，比如插头。你管它叫什么？
The plug? The plug. He takes the plug from Stanley. He wants to plug it in. He's like, just like Rockefeller Center. And everyone gathers around and it's like, and Phyllis is like, I'm sorry. And at six minutes, 38 seconds, you see my first pissed off face. Like, dang it, Phyllis. It's also one of those moments where I feel like Angela's like, I knew it. I knew it. I knew I couldn't trust her to do these lights. Why do I even have her do anything?
插头？插头。他从斯坦利那里拿过插头。他想把它插上。他说：“就像洛克菲勒中心一样。”每个人都围了过来，然后就像是……菲利斯说：“我很抱歉。”在6分38秒，你看到了我第一次生气的表情。就像是，该死，菲利斯。这也是那种我觉得安吉拉会想“我早就知道了”的时刻之一。我早就知道了。我知道我不能相信她能把这些灯弄好。为什么我还要让她做任何事？
Why do you have anyone do anything? You can't let anyone do anything. These people are worthless. Exactly. You know, that Christmas tree light thing is based on a real thing from Mike Schur's life. I know. He said that when he and his wife got their first tree in New York, he bought a bunch
为什么你要让任何人做任何事？你不能让任何人做任何事。这些人一无是处。没错。你知道，那个圣诞树灯的事情是基于迈克·舒尔生活中的一件真事。我知道。他说当他和妻子在纽约有了第一棵树时，他买了一堆
of small lights for the tree and he wrapped them around and when he plugged it in, you couldn't really see them. I love that. I love when writers work those little moments from their real life into the show. I thought, speaking about people who are acting like themselves instead of their characters, I thought Jim's talking head about Creed's gift is so John. It is John. That is John right there.
小灯挂在树上，他把它们缠上去，当他插上电源时，你根本看不见它们。我喜欢这个。我喜欢编剧们把他们现实生活中的那些小瞬间写进剧里。说到那些表现得像他们自己而不是角色的演员，我觉得吉姆关于克里德礼物的谈话头（talking head）太像约翰（John）了。那就是约翰。那就是约翰本人。
Yeah. All the delivery, the smile, all of it. And then of course, Creed's talking head made me laugh so hard. Creed is very funny in this episode. I mean, everybody has some great moments, but Creed cracked me up a bunch in this episode. So now Secret Santa is starting. Yep. And everyone is gathered around in some office chairs.
是的。所有的表达，微笑，所有的一切。然后当然，克里德的谈话头让我笑得好大声。克里德在这一集里非常有趣。我是说，每个人都有一些很棒的时刻，但克里德在这一集里让我笑了很多次。所以现在秘密圣诞老人开始了。是的。每个人都围坐在一些办公椅上。
And I want to say truly, I know we were joking about Charles McDougall, but the amount of energy and movement that he uses the camera to give this scene of people sitting in a circle, I mean, it is impressive from a directorial standpoint. I think, like, I don't want to be crazy, but I think, like, film students should study this portion of the episode because I'm imagining myself trying to film a group of people sitting in a circle doing a gift exchange,
我想说真的，我知道我们之前在开查尔斯·麦克杜格尔（Charles McDougall）的玩笑，但他利用摄像机给这个人们围坐一圈的场景带来的能量和运动，我是说，从导演的角度来看，这令人印象深刻。我想，我不想显得太疯狂，但我觉得，电影专业的学生应该研究这一集的这一部分，因为我在想象自己试图拍摄一群人围坐一圈交换礼物，
and it would not look nearly this dynamic. It's really, really impressive directing. No, he's great. He is really great. Okay, so we're starting The Secret Santa and Pam opens Jim's teapot. She loves it, but Dwight moves things along so quickly that she doesn't have time to look inside or notice the card that's in the box. Yeah, Dwight wants no chitty chat between gifts. He's like, go, go, go, go. He's me coming in today. He is. He's like, save it for the mic. So he's moving things along. So it's Pam. And then the next one.
它看起来绝对不会这么有活力。这真的是非常令人印象深刻的导演手法。不，他很棒。他真的很棒。好的，所以我们开始秘密圣诞老人，帕姆打开了吉姆的茶壶。她很喜欢，但德怀特推进得太快了，她没时间往里看，也没注意到盒子里有卡片。是的，德怀特不希望礼物之间有任何闲聊。他就像是，快，快，快，快。他就是今天进来的我。他就是。他就像是，留着以后再说。所以他在推进进度。所以是帕姆。然后下一个。
We find out that Michael buys Ryan a video iPod that costs $400. You guys, this was not product placement. It was not. So many people wanted to know. Yeah, we were not paid. It was just sort of a really cool topical gift at the time. Yeah. And they were trying to think of a gift that would sort of be a showstopper that Michael would think was very impressive that everyone would want.
我们发现迈克尔给瑞安买了一个价值400美元的视频iPod。伙计们，这不是植入式广告。真的不是。很多人想知道。是的，我们没拿钱。它只是当时一个非常酷的流行礼物。是的。他们试图想出一个礼物，既能成为焦点，迈克尔又会觉得非常令人印象深刻，每个人都会想要的。
So this was coincidence. We weren't paid to use it. So I read that, that... Well, here's the something. A ton of people wanted to know who kept it at the end. Nobody. We weren't allowed to keep any of the stuff. It all goes into a giant warehouse and it gets labeled for the episode for props because if for some reason we have to go back and reshoot something, they take it off the shelf and they bring it back in. That's true. I don't know what happens after it's been in the warehouse for a while, but it just goes to prop house storage. I feel like it's still in a box labeled the office Christmas party.
所以这纯属巧合。我们没拿钱用它。所以我读到过，那个……嗯，这里有个情况。很多人想知道最后是谁留下了它。没人。我们不允许留下任何东西。它们都被放进一个巨大的仓库，并为这一集贴上道具标签，因为如果出于某种原因我们需要回去重拍某些东西，他们会把它从架子上拿下来带回来。这是真的。我不知道在仓库里放了一段时间后会发生什么，但它只是去了道具仓库。我觉得它现在还在一个贴着“办公室圣诞派对”标签的盒子里。
Probably is. There was a fan question from BeardUpBeardDown, was the iPod sponsored by Apple? It wasn't. We said it was not. It's just a total coincidence. But there's more coincidence. So the week after this episode aired, Apple revealed that you could now
很可能还在。有一个来自BeardUpBeardDown的粉丝提问，iPod是苹果赞助的吗？不是。我们说了不是。这完全是巧合。但还有更多的巧合。所以这一集播出后的那一周，苹果透露你现在可以
download episodes of The Office onto these video iPods. Again, this was not planned. And then The Office became the number one downloaded show on iTunes. Yes. The number one downloaded show. I remember Rainn Wilson turned to me and said, I think we're gonna make it.
把《办公室》的剧集下载到这些视频iPod上。同样，这不是计划好的。然后《办公室》成为了iTunes上下载量排名第一的剧集。是的。下载量排名第一的剧集。我记得雷恩·威尔森（Rainn Wilson）转向我说：“我想我们要成功了。”
I think we're gonna, this was the first moment. It felt like the tide was turning for us and that we might not get canceled. All right, so next up, Michael gets his gift, the oven mitt knitted by Phyllis. Oof. Now everyone had a $20 limit, you guys. That's why this iPod really shakes everything up
“我想我们要……”这是第一个时刻。感觉风向正在为我们转变，我们可能不会被砍掉。好了，接下来，迈克尔得到了他的礼物，菲利斯织的烤箱手套。哎哟。现在每个人都有20美元的限额，伙计们。这就是为什么这个iPod真的让一切都乱套了
because he spent $400. Yes, yes. And he has his line where he says, I only, he says out in the hallway, he's holding the mitt and he says, do you know what this says? This says, I only care about you a homemade oven mitts worth. He is such a child. He is such a bratty kid in this episode.
因为他花了400美元。是的，是的。他有一句台词，他说，他在走廊里，手里拿着手套，他说：“你知道这说明什么吗？这说明，我只在乎你一个自制烤箱手套那么多。”他真是个孩子。他在这一集里真是个任性的孩子。
Oh my gosh. Well, we had a fan question from Chelsea, Raconza and Amanda and many others actually, who actually knitted the oven mitt. Well, I asked Phyllis, she does not knit in real life. Although she told me that she knitted a scarf for her mom a couple of years ago, but she said that's it. She didn't, oh, just one scarf. I want you guys to know,
天哪。嗯，我们有一个来自切尔西（Chelsea）、拉孔扎（Raconza）和阿曼达（Amanda）以及许多其他人的粉丝提问，到底是谁织的那个烤箱手套。嗯，我问了菲利斯，她在现实生活中不织毛衣。虽然她告诉我她几年前给她妈妈织过一条围巾，但她说就那一次。她没……哦，只是一条围巾。我想让你们知道，
you know how we talk about what was at everyone's desk? So at Phyllis's desk, like sitting on the floor sort of next to her desk for so many years, was a whole knitting basket. Do you remember? I do remember that. It had all the yarn and the knitting needles and it sat there as if her character would ever do anything with it.
你知道我们谈论过每个人的桌子上有什么吗？所以在菲利斯的桌子上，就像坐在她桌子旁边地板上好多年了，有一个完整的编织篮。你记得吗？我记得。里面有所有的毛线和织针，它就放在那里，好像她的角色真的会用它做点什么一样。
But it was established there and it sat there. Well Phil Shea told me he found a woman at a knitting store in Valley Village, California, and she knitted the Oven Mitt. Again, Oven Mitt knitter, if you're listening, please write us at officeladiesatearwolf.com and we'll give you a shout out. Yeah. Knitted the famous mitt. I thought it looked like a great Oven Mitt
但它就在那里，一直放着。嗯，菲尔·谢伊告诉我，他在加州山谷村（Valley Village）的一家编织店里找了一位女士，她织了那个烤箱手套。再次呼吁，烤箱手套的编织者，如果你在听，请写信给我们officeladiesatearwolf.com，我们会为你大声疾呼。是的。织了那个著名的手套。我觉得它看起来像个很棒的烤箱手套，
and it had like the little like a- Like the Teflon. Teflon-y thingy on the one side. Yeah. So Ryan gets the iPod, and at 8 minutes, 24 seconds is the next phase of Angela pissed-off-ness. You see my face at the fact that Michael spent $400 when the limit was 20.
而且它有一点点像……特氟龙（Teflon）。那一侧有特氟龙的东西。是的。所以瑞安得到了iPod，在8分24秒是安吉拉愤怒程度的下一个阶段。你看到了我的表情，因为迈克尔花了400美元，而限额是20美元。
All of my instructions, I'm sure I sent out an email about Secret Santa and the rules. So one, Phyllis has ignored my request for bigger lights and got the tiny lights. Now two, Michael has spent $400 instead of their agreed upon $20. So we're ramping up, she's getting ticked off. I have no doubt that you sent a very detailed email
我所有的指示，我肯定发过一封关于秘密圣诞老人和规则的邮件。所以第一，菲利斯无视了我对更大灯泡的要求，买了小灯泡。现在第二，迈克尔花了400美元，而不是他们商定的20美元。所以我们正在升级，她越来越生气了。我毫不怀疑你发了一封非常详细的邮件
about this to everyone with a follow-up reminder. Which is why Kevin does not come forward when he gets himself, because he would have had to tell me. He would have. Yeah. You know what? I really relate to Angela on so many levels. Listen.
关于这个给每个人，还有后续提醒。这就是为什么凯文在给自己买东西时没有站出来，因为他必须告诉我。他必须。是的。你知道吗？我在很多层面上都和安吉拉产生共鸣。听着。
I really do. There's on some levels, you're way more Angela than I am. Oh yeah. I mean, I would have generated two, three, four, very detailed emails about the party, the plans. If I assigned someone to do lights for the tree, and that's what I got, I would feel so pissed and let down.
我真的有。在某些层面上，你比我更像安吉拉。哦，是的。我是说，我会为派对、计划生成两、三、四封非常详细的邮件。如果我指派某人去给树装灯，而我得到的是那个，我会感到非常生气和失望。
If people went over the $20 budget, you would have been furious. Furious. Because you would have been like, what's the point? Why even have that number? Is Angela wrong? No, I don't think she's wrong. She's just, you know, why is no one helping her? She's a by the book person. Why can't people follow the rules?
如果人们超过了20美元的预算，你会非常愤怒。愤怒。因为你会想，意义何在？为什么要定那个数字？安吉拉错了吗？不，我不觉得她错了。她只是，你知道，为什么没有人帮她？她是一个按规矩办事的人。为什么人们不能遵守规则？
I agree. So at nine minutes, 39 seconds, she gets pissed off on a whole new level because as you were saying, this is when Michael is really ticked off that he got the oven mitt and he switches the party. No more secret Santa. He says, now we're doing Yankee Swap. Yes, Yankee Swap slash White Elephant slash, what was the other one he said?
我同意。所以在9分39秒，她达到了一个全新的愤怒水平，因为正如你所说，这是迈克尔因为收到烤箱手套而真正生气的时候，他改变了派对规则。不再是秘密圣诞老人。他说，现在我们要玩“洋基交换”。是的，“洋基交换”斜杠“白象”（White Elephant）斜杠，他说的另一个是什么？
Nasty Christmas. Nasty Christmas. You know, there was actually a little debate about what do you call it? And people were like, well, we call it White Elephant. And someone else was like, we call it Yankee Swap. And I feel like the writers took that and put it in the episode. Yeah, I know it as Yankee Swap. What do you know it as? I knew it as White Elephant. Yeah. I think it's good they did that.
“肮脏圣诞节”（Nasty Christmas）。“肮脏圣诞节”。你知道，关于叫什么其实有一点小争论。人们说，嗯，我们叫它“白象”。另一个人说，我们叫它“洋基交换”。我觉得编剧们采纳了这一点并把它放进了剧集里。是的，我知道它叫“洋基交换”。你知道它叫什么？我知道它叫“白象”。是的。我觉得他们这样做很好。
I do too. They covered everybody. They covered everybody. But when I threw my Christmas party, I called it Yankee Swap, just because I loved it so much. You know, here's something that I heard in the commentary, Angela, since we're talking about your character. I guess that you had a talking head in the fire. I watched it because I have a DVD player now.
我也这么觉得。他们涵盖了所有人。他们涵盖了所有人。但当我举办圣诞派对时，我叫它“洋基交换”，只是因为我太喜欢它了。你知道，这是我在评论音轨里听到的，安吉拉，既然我们在谈论你的角色。我猜你在火灾那一集里有一个谈话头。我看了，因为我现在有DVD播放机了。
Where you cry. Yes, in the deleted scenes. Well, Mike said that the writer's room was so impressed with your performance and that talking head that they put a card on the wall that was Angela cries and they wanted to find an episode where you could cry a bunch and this was it. Mike sure told me he said I love to see your character cry. He said she's so pulled together that when you sort of fall apart it's like really sort of oddly pleasing. Oh, I love it. I love it.
你哭了。是的，在删减片段里。嗯，迈克说编剧室对你的表演和那个谈话头印象深刻，他们在墙上贴了一张卡片，上面写着“安吉拉哭了”，他们想找一集让你大哭一场，这就是那一集。迈克·舒尔告诉我，他说我喜欢看你的角色哭。他说她平时太紧绷了，所以当你崩溃时，这看起来真的很奇怪地令人愉悦。哦，我喜欢它。我喜欢它。
So yes, at 9 minutes 51 seconds, I have a talking head. And my character is really upset because she feels like Michael should have talked to the PPC first. Yeah, well, they should have. And then she breaks down. So she is really starting to spiral. And then when we cut back to the scene, she's still sobbing. I mean, she's not sobbing, but she's still crying. She's sullen. She's very starting to spiral. And then when we cut back to the scene, she's still sobbing. I mean, she's not sobbing, but she's still crying.
所以是的，在9分51秒，我有一个谈话头。我的角色真的很沮丧，因为她觉得迈克尔应该先和PPC商量。是的，嗯，他们应该商量的。然后她崩溃了。所以她真的开始失控了。然后当我们切回场景时，她还在啜泣。我是说，她不是在啜泣，但她还在哭。她很阴郁。她非常开始失控了。然后当我们切回场景时，她还在啜泣。我是说，她不是在啜泣，但她还在哭。
She's sullen. She's very sullen. Okay, you know this famous line? -"Yankee swap!" From Michael? All right, Mike Schur, that's a written line that wasn't improvised, that Steve would say Yankee swap. And Mike wrote in the script in parentheses, crazy voice. And he was like, I know Steve will do something great with that. And that was Steve's take on that. Because they would
她很阴郁。她非常阴郁。好的，你知道这句名言吗？——“洋基交换！”来自迈克尔？好的，迈克·舒尔，那是一句写好的台词，不是即兴的，史蒂夫会说“洋基交换”。迈克在剧本的括号里写了“疯狂的声音”。他就像是，我知道史蒂夫会用那个做出很棒的效果。那就是史蒂夫对那个的演绎。因为他们会
do that. They would sometimes put little pieces of direction in the script for us and then we'd have to interpret it. Yeah. Guys, did you notice in this episode, it is snowing outside. I loved this touch. I love that they kept cutting to the windows and there'd be snow. Do you remember how much fun it was to have the snow? We were so tickled by the snow. We were so excited.
那样做。他们有时会在剧本里为我们写一点点指导，然后我们必须去解读它。是的。伙计们，你们注意到在这一集里，外面在下雪吗？我喜欢这个细节。我喜欢他们不断切到窗户，然后会有雪。你们还记得有雪是多么有趣吗？我们被雪逗乐了。我们太兴奋了。
You guys remember we mostly just filmed inside and we never even saw outside or what was happening outside. Yeah. And so the fact that we had this extra element happening was so fun. We really did film inside in a windowless warehouse. All the windows were fake. They just had backdrops behind them. So to see actual sunshine or snow or air was really exciting to us. I have a ton of facts about the snow. I don't know if anyone else will find it interesting, but I had written all about it in one of my blogs slash journals. I'm living for this. I
你们记得我们大部分时间只是在室内拍摄，甚至从没见过外面，或者外面发生了什么。是的。所以我们有这个额外元素的事实太有趣了。我们确实是在一个没有窗户的仓库里拍摄的。所有的窗户都是假的。它们后面只是背景板。所以看到真实的阳光或雪或空气对我们来说真的很令人兴奋。我有很多关于雪的事实。我不知道别人会不会觉得有趣，但我已经在我的一个博客/日记里写了所有关于它的事。我太期待这个了。我
can't wait to hear about it. I do have to pee. Oh, do you want me to give you some snow facts when we come back from the break? I mean, can I go pee? You should be on an empty bladder when I lay these awesome facts on you. You don't tell me or my bladder what we're doing.
等不及要听了。我确实得去尿尿。哦，你想让我回来休息后再给你讲一些雪的事实吗？我是说，我可以去尿尿吗？当我告诉你这些很棒的事实时，你应该排空膀胱。你不能告诉我或我的膀胱我们在做什么。
Well, what do you want? Do you want full bladder snow facts or empty bladder snow facts? I want empty bladder snow facts. All right, that's what I'm saying. Oh, I thought you were telling me that I had to not drink any more water or tea. When we go on a road trip, my husband will be like,
嗯，你想要什么？你想要满膀胱的雪事实还是空膀胱的雪事实？我想要空膀胱的雪事实。好的，这就是我要说的。哦，我还以为你在告诉我，我不能再喝水或茶了。当我们去公路旅行时，我丈夫会说，
can you not get a nice tea? Okay, clearly you're projecting some other thing on me because I said I thought you should empty your bladder for the snow facts she's leaving. First, you push away from the mic to eat your snack. This is for you, Jenna. So disgusting. Those are high nut Cheerios.
“你能不能别喝茶了？”好的，显然你在我身上投射了其他东西，因为我说过我觉得你应该为雪事实排空膀胱，她要走了。首先，你推开麦克风去吃零食。这是给你的，珍娜。太恶心了。那是高坚果麦圈（Cheerios）。
Oh God. ["Dreams of a New World"] Thank you for letting me have my bathroom break. I want to hear all about your snow. All right. I hope this isn't anticlimactic for people, but the company that came to make the snow is called Snow Business. I love that.
哦，天哪。[“新世界的梦想”] 谢谢你让我去洗手间。我想听听所有关于你的雪的事。好的。我希望这对大家来说不是虎头蛇尾，但制造雪的公司叫“雪生意”（Snow Business）。我喜欢这个。
Snow Business. Snow Business. I remembered. I remembered that. It so tickled me. Okay. So here's how it works with fake snow. There's a. I remembered that. It so tickled me. Okay, so here's how it works with fake snow. There's a guy from snow business. He shows up. Now, the snow that falls from the sky is different from the ground cover snow. The snow on the ground is snow. The snow that falls from
“雪生意”。“雪生意”。我记得。我记得那个。它太让我开心了。好的。所以这就是假雪的工作原理。有一个……我记得那个。它太让我开心了。好的，所以这就是假雪的工作原理。有一个来自“雪生意”的人。他出现了。现在，从天上掉下来的雪和地面的覆盖雪是不一样的。地上的雪是雪。从
the sky, I know, because it falls on my character at the end and it is not snow. It's not snow. It's soap. Yes, you can get a choice. You can get a choice of cornstarch, plastic, or soap. And Greg watched a demonstration of all three and he picked soap. Well, when by accident, a little piece of that might get in your mouth. It tastes like soap. Because I shriek and a piece of it went in my mouth.
天上掉下来的雪，我知道，因为它最后掉在了我的角色身上，那不是雪。那不是雪。那是肥皂。是的，你可以选择。你可以选择玉米淀粉、塑料或肥皂。格雷格（Greg）看了所有三种的演示，他选了肥皂。嗯，当不小心，那东西的一小块可能会进到你的嘴里。它尝起来像肥皂。因为我尖叫了，它的一块掉进了我的嘴里。
That's what she said. Yeah. Okay. On the ground though, it's real snow. And they bring this machine and I don't know exactly how it works, but it's kind of like a wood chipper, but in reverse. It looks like something out of a Dr. Seuss book. It does, it really does.
这就是她说的。是的。好的，不过在地上，那是真雪。他们带来了这台机器，我不知道它具体是怎么工作的，但它有点像木材粉碎机，但反过来。它看起来像是苏斯博士（Dr. Seuss）书里的东西。确实，真的。
And it really blows snow. I guess that's what it looks like. It looks like a snow blower, but it generates snow. And then it just blows it all over the ground, all over the cars and all that stuff. But guys, remember, this is like, we're shooting this in like October in Los Angeles and it's hot in October it stays warm here in the daytime it's still in the mid
它真的在吹雪。我猜这就是它看起来的样子。它看起来像个吹雪机，但它能产生雪。然后它只是把它吹得到处都是，吹到地上，吹到车上，所有那些东西。但伙计们，记住，这就像，我们在十月份在洛杉矶拍摄，十月份很热，白天这里依然很暖和，气温还在80多度、90多度，但那是晚上，所以我们有一点时间，我是说，外面还是很暖和，是的，可能在60多度，是的，听起来差不多。好的，是的，我们非常兴奋能有雪。珍娜，你喜欢我的雪事实吗？我现在对它们感到有点脆弱，因为我们铺垫了太多。我是说，有一个休息时间，现在我有了它。我喜欢你的雪事实。“雪生意”。很可爱。我觉得“雪生意”真的很可爱。好的。让我们回到礼物交换。这是凯利拿到安吉拉海报的时候，但安吉拉，你确实把它拿回来了。好的，是这样的。
80s 90s but it was night and so we had a little bit of time with it I mean it was still warm out yeah it was probably like in the high 60s yeah that sounds about right all right yes we were very excited to have snow and Jenna, where did you like my snow facts? I feel a little vulnerable about them now because we set them up so much. I mean, there was like a break and now I had about it. I like your snow facts. Snow business. That's cute. I think snow business is really cute. All right. Let's go back to the gift exchange. This is when Kelly gets Angela's poster, but Angela, you do get to take it back. Okay, here's the thing.
80多度、90多度，但那是晚上，所以我们还有一点时间，我的意思是外面还是很暖和。是的，气温大概在60多度吧。是的，听起来差不多。好的，是的，我们对下雪感到非常兴奋。珍娜，你喜欢我的雪知识吗？我现在对它们感到有点不安，因为我们铺垫了太久。我的意思是，中间休息了一下，现在我又要说了。我喜欢你的雪知识。雪生意（Snow business）。这很可爱。我觉得“雪生意”真的很可爱。好了，让我们回到礼物交换环节。这是凯利拿到安吉拉海报的时候，但是安吉拉，你确实把它拿回去了。好吧，事情是这样的。
I wrote in my MySpace blog about this moment, and I wrote that it was one of the hardest things for us to get through as a cast, that the first time Mindy unrolls the poster and looks at it and we all see it, we all, every person lost it. Because it's so ridiculous. It's so ridiculous, we had not seen it. It was an actual surprise to us while we were filming and we all lost it.
我在我的MySpace博客里写过这一刻，我写道，这是我们作为演员最难熬过的事情之一，第一次敏迪展开海报看着它，我们所有人都看到了，我们所有，每个人都崩溃了。因为它太荒谬了。它太荒谬了，我们之前没见过。在我们拍摄时，这确实是一个惊喜，我们所有人都崩溃了。
I had that in fact, it was particularly hard on Rain for some reason and that in one take, he broke three times because he could not get through it. I can't believe that Mindy was tasked with having to unroll that poster. How did we ever get a shot of her not laughing? I don't know, but we were cracking up. There's a little detail in that scene that made me laugh when I rewatched it, which is
我确实有那个事实，出于某种原因，这对雷恩来说特别难，在一次拍摄中，他笑了三次，因为他无法坚持下去。我不敢相信敏迪被指派去展开那张海报。我们是怎么拍到她没笑的镜头的？我不知道，但我们当时笑得前仰后合。那一幕里有一个小细节，当我重看时让我笑了，那就是
how you just very subtly swat the oven mitt away on your way to getting the poster. That was all me. Thank you very much. I loved it. It was such a good detail. I loved it. Well, in tracking the oven mitt, Meredith eventually takes the oven mitt. But, you know, Michael has to then call her a sucker and say that he wanted her to take it. And it was reverse psychology when he said he wanted to keep it. I love that he decided that he needed to break down reverse psychology to all of us. I don't know if you've heard of it. It's a pretty cool thing. I'm like, Michael, you're such an idiot. Do you remember how Phyllis cried during that scene?
你刚才在去拿海报的路上，非常巧妙地把烤箱手套拨开。那全是我自己发挥的。非常感谢。我很喜欢。那是一个非常棒的细节。我很喜欢。嗯，在追踪烤箱手套的过程中，梅雷迪思最终拿走了它。但是，你知道，迈克尔随后不得不叫她傻瓜，并说他本来就想让她拿走。当他说他想留着它时，那是反向心理学。我喜欢他决定向我们所有人解释什么是反向心理学。我不知道你们有没有听说过。那是个很酷的东西。我当时心想，迈克尔，你真是个白痴。你还记得菲利斯在那场戏里是怎么哭的吗？
Yeah, she stayed in like sort of that sad place. She cried for like a half hour and in between takes of that where she had to be crying. She didn't want any of us to talk to her and Kate and I tried to go up and give her a hug. She didn't want it like she was in this like actor zone. It's so hard to do. It's so hard to do. I know exactly where she was, but I just remember being really worried for her because when you see Phyllis cry, it is, oh, you don't want to see Phyllis cry because it breaks every part of you open. I mean, she did, she had to stay sad and it is really hard, especially sitting in this circle
是的，她一直处于那种悲伤的状态。她哭了大约半个小时，在需要哭泣的拍摄间隙，她不想让我们任何人跟她说话，凯特和我试着走过去给她一个拥抱。她不想要，就像她进入了那种演员的专注状态。这太难做到了。这真的太难了。我完全明白她的处境，但我只记得当时真的很为她担心，因为当你看到菲利斯哭时，哦，你不想看到菲利斯哭，因为它会让你心碎。我的意思是，她必须保持悲伤，这真的很难，尤其是在这个圈子里
with people cracking up about a baby poster. But you've got to stay sad. Yes. It's hard. It's really hard. It's very difficult. Well, here's the thing. Michael just gets progressively meaner.
大家都在因为一张婴儿海报而笑得前仰后合。但你必须保持悲伤。是的。这很难。真的很难。这非常困难。嗯，问题是，迈克尔变得越来越刻薄了。
You know, he calls Meredith a sucker and then Dwight, you know, he opens the paintball and he's like, you know, how is this better than an iPod? And this moment kind of broke my heart too when Dwight goes, I never said it was better, you know? Wait, I have an Angela pissed off in this moment. Oh, okay, go. At 13 minutes, 58 seconds, look at my face.
你知道，他叫梅雷迪思傻瓜，然后德怀特，你知道，他打开了彩弹枪，他说，你知道，这怎么比iPod更好？当德怀特说“我从来没说它更好”时，这一刻也让我心碎了，你知道吗？等等，我在这场戏里有安吉拉生气的镜头。哦，好的，来吧。在13分58秒，看我的脸。
I wrote it in all caps. So Michael has just called Meredith a sucker because she got the lame oven mitt and Phyllis storms out, okay? She is completely heartbroken now and the party is falling apart and the look on my face is just sheer in like rage. Now are we at the top of your rage now? No. Oh no. Well I mean I know we've still got the parking lot
我用大写字母写下来了。所以迈克尔刚刚叫梅雷迪思傻瓜，因为她拿到了那个蹩脚的烤箱手套，然后菲利斯冲了出去，好吗？她现在完全心碎了，派对正在分崩离析，我脸上的表情简直是纯粹的愤怒。现在我们达到你愤怒的顶峰了吗？没有。哦，不。嗯，我的意思是，我知道我们还有停车场那场戏
but. No. Oh no. There's a moment coming and you'll know it. It's the there's there's a one-two punch coming at the end for my anger. But yeah. All right, so people are making trades and feelings are getting hurt. Yeah. And Pam does not go back and get the teapot. She gets the iPod. She does. When it's Pam's turn to pick again, she picks the iPod instead of the teapot. And Jim is so hurt. He's so hurt. And I, you know, I watched this and I was like, come on, Pam. But then, you know, Pam doesn't know what all is in the teapot. She doesn't. And that's what sort of justified it for me. She's just like, this is an iPod.
但是。没有。哦，不。有一个时刻即将到来，你会知道的。我的愤怒在最后有一个组合拳。但是，是的。好吧，所以人们在进行交换，感情受到了伤害。是的。帕姆没有回去拿茶壶。她拿了iPod。她确实拿了。当轮到帕姆再次选择时，她选择了iPod而不是茶壶。吉姆非常受伤。他非常受伤。而且，你知道，我看了这一幕，我心想，拜托，帕姆。但是，你知道，帕姆不知道茶壶里有什么。她不知道。这就是为什么这对我来说是合理的。她只是觉得，这是一个iPod。
This iPod has completely hijacked this whole fun party and gift exchange because everybody who's sitting in the seat is just thinking about trying to get this iPod. And so is Pam. Unfortunately, I think she kind of forgot about the teapot. So it was her time to pick. She was just like, iPod. But she also doesn't know what's in the teapot. She doesn't.
这个iPod完全劫持了整个有趣的派对和礼物交换，因为每个坐在座位上的人都在想着怎么得到这个iPod。帕姆也是。不幸的是，我想她有点忘了茶壶的事。所以轮到她选的时候，她只是想，iPod。但她也不知道茶壶里有什么。她不知道。
She doesn't know how high the stakes are for Jim. No. She doesn't. I think it's kind of an innocent moment, honestly. And Michael has ruined all of this because the gifts were specific for people. I mean, Ryan gets a placard that says Kelly. Yeah.
她不知道这对吉姆来说赌注有多高。不。她不知道。老实说，我觉得这是一个很无辜的时刻。迈克尔毁了这一切，因为礼物是专门为特定的人准备的。我的意思是，瑞安得到了一块写着凯利名字的牌子。是的。
He gets like, you know, a desk, whatever, nameplate. Yeah. Like these were not meant to be Yankee swap gifts. They were not. They were meant for certain people. Well, at this point, the party has completely broken down and Michael goes to the liquor store. Now I want to point out a few things.
他得到了一块，你知道，桌子，什么的，名牌。是的。这些本来就不是为了“洋基交换”准备的礼物。它们不是。它们是为特定的人准备的。嗯，此时，派对已经完全崩溃了，迈克尔去了酒类商店。现在我想指出几件事。
I know what you're going to point out because lady, I have the DVDs now. So go do it. Do you know what I'm going to say? Is it about the attendant at the liquor store? I have one thing to say about him, but I just thought I wanted to point out that it's also snowing outside the window of the liquor store. Yeah. They made it snow there too. I don't know. Nice detail.
我知道你要指出什么，因为女士，我现在有DVD了。所以去做吧。你知道我要说什么吗？是关于酒类商店的店员吗？关于他我有一件事要说，但我只是想指出，酒类商店的窗外也在下雪。是的。他们也在那里制造了雪景。我不知道。不错的细节。
Nice touch. Good continuity. V. They made it snow there too. I don't know. Nice detail. Nice touch. Good continuity. Veda was on it. Well, I read that our writers found out in Pennsylvania that if you work at a liquor store, you have to wear a tie. Yes. And so that was part of this character description is that he had to have on a tie. Isn't that great? And I thought the actor, his name is Ryan Martin, did a fantastic job. He just really like takes in all of that vodka. 15 bottles. 15 bottles. Craziness. Okay, so then we go back to the party. Michael brings all this vodka back into the party and at 16, 10 minutes, this is the next phase of Angela, Angela's spiral. Oh, say it. So Michael has vodka and she's like, what are you doing?
不错的点缀。很好的连续性。维达（Veda）很用心。嗯，我读到我们的编剧发现，在宾夕法尼亚州，如果你在酒类商店工作，你必须打领带。是的。所以这是角色描述的一部分，他必须打领带。这不是很棒吗？我觉得那个演员，他叫瑞安·马丁，表现得非常出色。他真的像是把所有的伏特加都喝进去了。15瓶。15瓶。太疯狂了。好吧，然后我们回到派对。迈克尔把所有的伏特加带回了派对，在16分10秒，这是安吉拉螺旋式崩溃的下一个阶段。哦，说出来吧。所以迈克尔有伏特加，她说，你在做什么？
There's no alcohol at the party. You know, Angela speaks up and Toby speaks up. No one else cares. But now she's like- Toby speaks up, I miss that. Yeah, Toby's like, Michael, we really shouldn't have. And he goes, just shut it, Toby, it's a party. But then later I feel like Toby brings Todd Packer a drink.
派对上没有酒精。你知道，安吉拉开口了，托比也开口了。没人在乎。但现在她说——托比开口了，我错过了那个。是的，托比说，迈克尔，我们真的不应该这样。然后他说，闭嘴，托比，这是派对。但后来我觉得托比给托德·帕克拿了一杯酒。
Well, no, it's all, all, like all bets are off. And, and you know, you have to remember that Michael told the party planning committee that he wanted this Christmas party to be like, and I quote, a Playboy Mansion party. Yeah. That was his hope. That's his goal.
嗯，不，一切，一切，就像一切都无所谓了。而且，你知道，你必须记住，迈克尔告诉派对策划委员会，他希望这个圣诞派对像，我引用一下，“花花公子豪宅派对”。是的。那是他的希望。那是他的目标。
That's his goal. So, but yeah, Angela is now super ticked cause now there's alcohol. I'm surprised her whole head didn't explode. Well, it's about to cause the next two are what set it into motion. Oh boy. Well, now we have the scene where Jim is trying
那是他的目标。所以，但是是的，安吉拉现在超级生气，因为现在有酒精了。我很惊讶她的头没爆炸。嗯，快要爆炸了，因为接下来的两件事让它开始了。哦，天哪。好吧，现在我们有吉姆试图
to get the teapot back from Dwight. Jim offers to trade him the Shamrock key chain and he says, come on, it'll be good luck. And that's when Dwight has his line, a real man makes his own luck. Billy Zane, Titanic, and Angela. You made the entire cast t-shirts with that quote on them. And I still have mine.
从德怀特那里拿回茶壶的场景。吉姆提出用三叶草钥匙扣和他交换，他说，拜托，这会带来好运的。然后德怀特说了那句台词，“真正的男人会创造自己的运气”。比利·赞恩，《泰坦尼克号》，还有安吉拉。你给整个剧组做了印有那句台词的T恤。我还有我的那件。
Oh my gosh, you do? I do, it's a gray long sleeve t-shirt. Yes, with black writing. Just a quote across it. Yeah, so I had a friend at the time gray long sleeve t-shirt. Yes, with black writing. Just a quote across it. Yeah. So I had a friend at the time who had a t-shirt press because she had a small business. And I loved this line so much. I thought it was hilarious.
哦，天哪，你还有？我有，那是一件灰色长袖T恤。是的，上面有黑色字。就是那句引语。是的，当时我有一个朋友，她有一台T恤印刷机，因为她经营一家小企业。我太喜欢这句台词了。我觉得它太搞笑了。
Of all people for Dwight to quote, it would be Billy Zane. Well, people were asking if we gave each other gifts. That was a gift. You gave that out. I think you actually gave that out at Christmas that year. I did. And you gave everyone an ornament. Yes, I got that cast photo, and I had it printed
在所有人中，德怀特引用了比利·赞恩的话。嗯，人们问我们是否互赠礼物。那是一个礼物。你把它发了出去。我想你那年圣诞节确实把它发了出去。我确实发了。而且你给了每个人一个装饰品。是的，我拿到了那张剧组照片，我把它印在了
on an ornament for everyone. Yep. Aw. The idea that Dwight wants to keep the teapot in order to wash out his nasal passages with green tea is based on something that Greg Daniels has actually done. Like with a neti pot? Yeah, I mean, but I've actually done. Like with a neti pot? Yeah, I mean, but I've never put green tea in a neti pot.
一个装饰品上送给每个人。是的。啊。德怀特想留着茶壶来用绿茶清洗鼻腔的想法是基于格雷格·丹尼尔斯实际做过的事情。就像用洗鼻壶一样？是的，我的意思是，但我确实做过。就像用洗鼻壶一样？是的，我的意思是，但我从来没在洗鼻壶里放过绿茶。
I haven't either. I've only used the saline solution that is recommended. But I could see Greg reading about it and giving it a try. But Rain, the way Rain was in that scene, and he like shoved that teapot into his nostril. Yeah. And just John's face as Jim is just like,
我也没放过。我只用过推荐的生理盐水。但我能想象格雷格读到过这个并尝试了一下。但是雷恩，雷恩在那场戏里的样子，他把那个茶壶塞进他的鼻孔里。是的。还有约翰作为吉姆的表情，就像是，
are you kidding me? That, that's who gets my teapot? Like it's so perfect. He's so bummed. Now, when I watched this with Lee, Lee said he wondered how Dwight didn't find the note in the box or how Dwight didn't open up the teapot.
你在开玩笑吗？这就是拿到我茶壶的人？这太完美了。他太沮丧了。现在，当我和李一起看这一幕时，李说他想知道德怀特怎么没发现盒子里的纸条，或者德怀特怎么没打开茶壶。
I thought of all of those things. I thought Dwight now has the cassette and the sauce packet. I mean, so you have to sort of suspend belief, I guess, at that moment that he took those out and just shoved them aside like, hmm, what's this crap? And just sort of shoved them aside in the box. Well, also, I don't think Jim is trying to get the teapot back for Pam. I think he's just trying to get the teapot back for himself. He's just going to keep it now. That's what I think the motivation is there because Pam is over,
我想到了所有这些事情。我想德怀特现在有了磁带和酱料包。我的意思是，所以你必须在那个时刻暂停怀疑，我想，他把那些拿出来，只是把它们推到一边，就像，嗯，这是什么垃圾？然后只是把它们推到盒子里。嗯，还有，我不认为吉姆试图为帕姆拿回茶壶。我觉得他只是想为自己拿回茶壶。他现在只是想留着它。这就是我认为那里的动机，因为帕姆在
you know, up at the desk with Roy looking through her new iPod. I think Jim just wants to get it back because I think there's things inside it that are embarrassing. Yes, exactly. But he's gonna trade the key chain and he's just gonna take that teapot home now. So Pam is up at reception and she's showing Roy her new iPod. He's now at the party.
桌子那边和罗伊一起看她的新iPod。我觉得吉姆只是想拿回来，因为我觉得里面有令人尴尬的东西。是的，完全正确。但他要用钥匙扣交换，他现在要把那个茶壶带回家。所以帕姆在接待处，她正在向罗伊展示她的新iPod。他现在在派对上。
He wasn't there for Yankee Swap, but he's all excited because now he doesn't have to buy it for Pam for Christmas. He was going to buy her this iPod, he tells her, and now he doesn't have to or he's just gonna get her a sweater. Thanks, Roy. Now the party is like 15 bottles of vodka in,
他没参加“洋基交换”，但他很兴奋，因为现在他不用为帕姆买圣诞礼物了。他本来要给她买这个iPod，他告诉她，现在他不用买了，或者他只是给她买件毛衣。谢谢你，罗伊。现在派对已经喝了15瓶伏特加了，
Todd Packer has showed up. Oh yeah. It's getting crazy and- Everyone's doing shots, Angela's fuming. I am fuming, but the icing on the cake of my pissed-off-ness is about to happen. Oh, say it. Michael shouts to the whole bullpen. He says, oh my gosh, yes, Ryan, the king
托德·帕克出现了。哦，是的。变得疯狂了，而且——每个人都在喝烈酒，安吉拉在冒火。我在冒火，但我愤怒的顶峰即将到来。哦，说出来吧。迈克尔对整个办公室大喊。他说，哦，天哪，是的，瑞安，派对策划的
of the party planning. Oh, thank you to thank you to Ryan for this awesome party. And the camera pans to me and I am livid. Ryan the temp, the king of the party planning committee. Are you kidding me? Yeah. Oh, that's it. She is pissed. Oh, no. And it's only going to get worse. That's not even still the worst thing that's happened to Angela.
国王。哦，谢谢，谢谢瑞安举办了这个很棒的派对。镜头转向我，我气疯了。瑞安这个临时工，派对策划委员会的国王。你在开玩笑吗？是的。哦，就是这样。她气疯了。哦，不。而且情况只会变得更糟。那甚至还不是安吉拉发生的最糟糕的事情。
Nope. I had a headache by the end of this episode. You must have. You were just scowling and pushing anger out of your temples this whole episode. You know when Todd Packer shows up and he has that line, what's up, my nerds? That was an improv, sort of. In the script, what was written was, what's up, nerds? And he just gave it that extra special touch of what's up, my nerds?
不。这一集结束时我头痛欲裂。你肯定是的。你这一整集都在皱着眉头，从太阳穴里散发出愤怒。你知道当托德·帕克出现时，他说了那句，“嘿，我的书呆子们，怎么了？”那是一种即兴发挥。在剧本里，写的是，“嘿，书呆子们，怎么了？”他只是给了它那种特别的触感，“嘿，我的书呆子们，怎么了？”
I know. Well, that's also Dave Keckner. I mean, I think even the line when he's like, Packer need a drinky. Yeah. The line was probably like, he was getting me a drink. Yeah. You know, he brought so much to that role. It was amazing. And well, you know, when he has to lay down on the desk and get the silly string on him, like when he passes out, I remember shooting that he had to lay there forever. So he laid down on those desks which were not comfortable, right? And then they silly stringed his head. And then we had all these scenes where that's what he's doing. Well, if he got up, all the stuff that he was decorated in would have fallen off, it would have been impossible
我知道。嗯，那也是戴夫·科克纳。我的意思是，我觉得即使是当他说“帕克需要喝一杯”那句台词时。是的。台词可能就像是，他要给我拿杯酒。是的。你知道，他为那个角色贡献了很多。太棒了。而且，嗯，你知道，当他不得不躺在桌子上，身上沾满彩带时，就像他昏倒的时候，我记得拍摄那场戏时，他必须躺在那里很久。所以他躺在那些不舒服的桌子上，对吧？然后他们把彩带喷在他的头上。然后我们拍了所有他那样做的场景。嗯，如果他起来，他身上装饰的所有东西都会掉下来，那将是不可能
to recreate. So he had to just lay there even when we were on a break. Even when we were on a break. And he was such a trooper. Talk about a trooper. And I wrote in my MySpace blog that Kate and I, because Kate and I knew Dave from improv days. We had all done improv shows together. That Kate and I walked over and talked to him while he had to lay on his back.
重现的。所以即使我们在休息时，他也必须躺在那里。即使我们在休息时。他真是个硬汉。说到硬汉。我在我的MySpace博客上写道，凯特和我，因为凯特和我从即兴表演的日子就认识戴夫。我们都一起做过即兴表演。凯特和我走过去和他说话，当时他不得不躺在背上。
And we just sort of caught up, and that it was so fun to see him. But I want you guys to know, if you're wondering what Todd Packer looks like at 20 minutes 19 seconds to really paint a picture here. He's laying on his back kind of across a desk part area partition right in the middle of the room. He has blue silly string on his head, Christmas lights around his torso, a Christmas garland around his torso, Dwight's desk nameplate on his stomach and there's like a red empty solo cup kind of just like in his like the crook
我们只是叙叙旧，看到他真是太有趣了。但我希望你们知道，如果你想知道托德·帕克在20分19秒是什么样子，来描绘一下画面。他躺在背上，横跨在房间中间的一个桌子隔断区域。他的头上缠着蓝色的彩带，躯干周围缠着圣诞灯，躯干周围缠着圣诞花环，肚子上放着德怀特的桌子名牌，还有一个红色的空Solo杯子就在他手臂的弯曲处。
of his arm. You know, he had to lay like that with all those things on top of him. He passes out so quickly. You have to imagine he showed up already half drunk. You know he did. You know he did. You know he did Okay guys, so now we have the scene where Pam reveals to Jim that she got her teapot back She trades Dwight the iPod for the teapot and now she's gonna look inside and find all the items and it's very And now she's going to look inside and find all the items. And it's very charming and sweet, and she is so delighted. But in this moment, Jim secretly steals the note back and puts it in his pocket.
你知道，他必须那样躺着，身上放着所有那些东西。他昏倒得太快了。你必须想象他出现时已经半醉了。你知道他喝了。你知道他喝了。你知道他喝了。好吧，伙计们，现在我们有帕姆向吉姆透露她拿回茶壶的场景。她用iPod和德怀特交换了茶壶，现在她要往里看，找到所有的物品，这非常——而且现在她要往里看，找到所有的物品。这非常迷人且甜蜜，她非常高兴。但在这一刻，吉姆偷偷把纸条拿回来放进了口袋。
I know. He lost his courage. He did. Now, when we reached out to fans to ask them what they wanted to know about the Christmas episode. I would say that about 80% of the comments and emails we received were along the lines of what is in the teapot note. Because as you know, in this episode, Pam does not read it, it is not revealed. But then in season nine, there's a scene
我知道。他失去了勇气。他确实失去了。现在，当我们联系粉丝询问他们想了解关于圣诞特辑的什么时。我会说我们收到的评论和电子邮件中大约80%都是关于茶壶纸条里写了什么。因为如你所知，在这一集中，帕姆没有读它，它没有被揭示。但在第九季，有一个场景
where Jim has the documentary film crew put together footage of their romance and he shows it to Pam and Pam sees that there was a note that Jim steals back and then he hands it to her and she reads it. How brilliant is that? And you know who that is? That's Greg Daniels. Yeah. Because he was such a master at beautiful callback moments. such a master at beautiful callback moments. Mm-hmm. I love that. Well, from the time that Jim stole the note, it drove people crazy.
吉姆让纪录片摄制组把他们浪漫的片段剪辑在一起，他给帕姆看，帕姆看到有一张纸条是吉姆拿回来的，然后他递给她，她读了。这太天才了。你知道那是谁吗？那是格雷格·丹尼尔斯。是的。因为他是美丽的回应时刻的大师。美丽的回应时刻的大师。嗯哼。我喜欢那个。嗯，从吉姆偷走纸条的那一刻起，它就让人们抓狂。
They always wanted to know what had been written in the note. Would Pam ever get the note? For years and years, will he ever give her the note? Around the time of the wedding, people wanted him to give it to her as a wedding gift. Greg saved it till the end. I'm going to say something that I've never said before. I also feel like I'm maybe gonna cry. What? Wait. Wait.
他们总是想知道纸条上写了什么。帕姆会读到那张纸条吗？多年来，他会给她那张纸条吗？在婚礼前后，人们希望他把它作为结婚礼物送给她。格雷格把它留到了最后。我要说一些我从未说过的话。我也觉得我可能要哭了。什么？等等。等等。
What? Are you gonna say what was in the note? Are you gonna say what was in the note? Sort of. Because I don't know what was on that card. None of us do. I'm the only one who knows and John knows. Oh my gosh, lady. In that episode in season nine, I believe Greg suggested to John that he write a personal message from himself to me. Just saying what our time together on the office meant to him. Because we were wrapping up filming, we were wrapping up the series, and we were all
什么？你要说纸条里写了什么吗？你要说纸条里写了什么吗？算是吧。因为我不知道那张卡片上写了什么。我们谁都不知道。我是唯一知道的人，约翰也知道。哦，天哪，女士。在第九季的那一集中，我相信格雷格建议约翰写一段他自己给我的个人信息。只是说我们在一起在《办公室》的时光对他意味着什么。因为我们快要结束拍摄了，我们快要结束这个系列了，我们当时都
so emotional at that time, you know? We were all sort of saying goodbye in different ways. We were. And so that was his goodbye. Very similar to when we filmed that scene with Steve, where I said goodbye to him at the airport, and Paul Feig told me, just run up and say goodbye to your friend Steve. Jeff Blitz said the same thing to me when I was in the car with Oscar, and I say I love Dwight.
太情绪化了，你知道吗？我们都在以不同的方式告别。我们确实是。所以那是他的告别。非常类似于我们拍摄史蒂夫的那场戏，我在机场和他告别，保罗·费格告诉我，跑过去和你朋友史蒂夫告别。杰夫·布里茨在我坐在奥斯卡的车里时也对我说了同样的话，我说我爱德怀特。
He said, Angela, in this moment, express your love for the show and everyone and if you couldn't have it in your life anymore. And I disintegrated. Yeah. So, I'm on camera and I open up this note that John's written me and I just start crying. I just start bawling. It probably, the first take was probably not usable. It was the sweetest note.
他说，安吉拉，在这一刻，表达你对这部剧和每个人的爱，如果你不能再在生活中拥有它了。然后我就崩溃了。是的。所以，我在镜头前，打开了约翰写给我的这张纸条，我开始哭。我开始嚎啕大哭。可能，第一次拍摄可能无法使用。那是最甜蜜的纸条。
And you know, on camera, Pam says, I'll never say what it said, but just know it was perfect. Well, I'll never say exactly what John wrote, but I will say just know it was perfect. So that's what was in the teapot note, guys. It was a note from John to me. A personal note about what it meant to work with you on the show. Yeah. About our time together on the show. And it was really sweet. Well, that would completely wreck me.
而且你知道，在镜头前，帕姆说，我永远不会说它写了什么，但只要知道它是完美的就行了。嗯，我永远不会说约翰确切写了什么，但我会说，只要知道它是完美的就行了。所以这就是茶壶纸条里的内容，伙计们。那是约翰写给我的纸条。一张关于在剧中与你合作意味着什么的个人纸条。是的。关于我们在一起在剧中的时光。而且真的很甜蜜。嗯，那会彻底击垮我。
Oh, I love that. I didn't know that. Are you okay? Yeah. Well, crap. How do we talk about anything else? That was so beautiful. I'm sorry. That was so beautiful. I love that that was the direction that Greg gave. Those moments became very honest for us under that kind of direction. Yeah. And we all had little moments like that. That's a really big one though. Well, there were those moments on the show that were surprises. Yeah. Steve didn't know I was gonna run up and tell him that basically that same thing,
哦，我喜欢那个。我不知道。你还好吗？是的。嗯，该死。我们怎么谈论别的事情？那太美了。对不起。那太美了。我喜欢那是格雷格给出的指导。在那种指导下，那些时刻对我们来说变得非常真实。是的。我们都有过那样的小时刻。不过那是一个非常大的时刻。嗯，剧中有那些令人惊喜的时刻。是的。史蒂夫不知道我会跑过去告诉他，基本上就是我对他说的同样的事情，
Steve, I'm gonna miss you, you know, all the things that I said to him. Oscar didn't know the note that Jeff Blitz gave me. Yeah. So when all that emotion came, it was very like completely out of nowhere for him. Yeah. Okay, well, geez Louise.
史蒂夫，我会想念你的，你知道，所有我对他说的话。奥斯卡不知道杰夫·布里茨给我的纸条。是的。所以当所有的情绪涌上来时，对他来说非常像完全出乎意料。是的。好吧，好吧，天哪。
I'm sorry. That's okay. Where are we at in this episode? Well, we're at the moment when Kelly approaches Dwight in the kitchen. Kelly, that huzzy. Ooh, with her hair half down, half up. I know, she goes up to my man and lays one on him.
对不起。没关系。我们这一集进行到哪了？嗯，我们进行到凯利在厨房接近德怀特的时刻。凯利，那个荡妇。哦，她的头发一半放下，一半扎起。我知道，她走到我的男人面前，吻了他。
She does. And Angela sees it, and that is it. A lot of people wrote in and commented that you're standing in front of a poster that says commitment. Am I really? Yes. Oh my gosh, I didn't even notice. That is so funny.
她确实吻了。安吉拉看到了，就是这样。很多人写信评论说你站在一张写着“承诺”的海报前。我真的站在那吗？是的。哦，天哪，我甚至没注意到。这太搞笑了。
I think I was just so focused on the scene. Yeah. Wow. Yes. Angela loses it. Oh my gosh, I didn't even notice. That is so funny. I think I was just so focused on the scene. Wow, yes, Angela loses it, loses it. And this takes us outside. She's left the party and now I have some stuff to tell you guys about this scene. All right, 20 minutes, 16 seconds. The ultimate Angela pissed offness has happened.
我想我当时太专注于那场戏了。是的。哇。是的，安吉拉失控了。哦，天哪，我甚至没注意到。这太搞笑了。我想我当时太专注于那场戏了。哇，是的，安吉拉失控了，失控了。这把我们带到了外面。她离开了派对，现在我有一些关于这场戏的事情要告诉你们。好吧，20分16秒。安吉拉愤怒的终极时刻发生了。
Here's some behind the scenes of this scene. You have a guy up on the roof and he's got the soap snow. Yep. That he's gonna- Falling into your eyes. He's gonna, yeah. It's stinging. And then there's snow on the ground
这里有一些这场戏的幕后花絮。屋顶上有一个人，他拿着肥皂雪。是的。他要——掉进你的眼睛里。他要，是的。很刺痛。然后地上有雪
because they've put real snow on the ground. We filmed this scene at the end of the day and everyone had gone. It was just me and Charles McDougall, Randall Einhorn and Mike Schur. So it was just a kind of a skeleton crew everyone had gone. It was just me and Charles McDougall, Randall Einhorn and Mike Schur. So it was just a kind of a skeleton crew at this point. Those are always some of my most favorite shoots. Yeah, me too.
因为他们在地上放了真雪。我们在一天结束时拍摄了这场戏，大家都走了。只有我和查尔斯·麦克杜格尔、兰德尔·艾因霍恩和迈克·舒尔。所以当时只有一小部分核心工作人员。那些总是我最喜欢的拍摄之一。是的，我也是。
And we did not have a lot of time. We didn't have a lot of time to get this. The clock was ticking. Yeah, exactly. Because we didn't want to go into overtime for everyone. And it was the end of the day. And so Charles McDougall said to me, we're probably only going to do like two takes,
而且我们没有太多时间。我们没有太多时间来完成这个。时间在流逝。是的，没错。因为我们不想让每个人都加班。而且那是这一天的结束。所以查尔斯·麦克杜格尔对我说，我们可能只会拍两遍，
you know, maybe three. But they gave me these ornaments and my instruction was that my character has just lost it. Michael has ruined Christmas. Kelly has kissed my man. Ryan is the king of the party planning committee. Right? Yes. He said, I want you to take these ornaments and just throw them and shatter them. They were written in the script as glass ornaments. They were not glass ornaments. What? Watch the scene. I throw them down, they bounce straight up in the air.
你知道，也许三遍。但他们给了我这些装饰品，我的指令是我的角色已经失控了。迈克尔毁了圣诞节。凯利吻了我的男人。瑞安是派对策划委员会的国王。对吧？是的。他说，我希望你拿这些装饰品，把它们扔掉并砸碎。剧本里写的是玻璃装饰品。它们不是玻璃装饰品。什么？看那场戏。我把它们扔下去，它们直接弹向空中。
What were they? They were like some kind of plastic composite, whatever. Oh no. So when you look, watch it, you guys, you see them bounce in the air. I assumed, well that makes sense. We did not have the budget to get special breakaway glass ornaments and there's no way they would give you real glass. No. So these things bounced like a tennis ball and so Charles is like cut and he goes okay two things. One, we need you to stand closer to the wall.
它们是什么？它们是某种塑料复合材料，什么的。哦，不。所以当你看着，看吧，伙计们，你看到它们在空中弹起。我以为，嗯，这说得通。我们没有预算去买特殊的易碎玻璃装饰品，而且他们不可能给你真正的玻璃。不。所以这些东西像网球一样弹起来，所以查尔斯喊停，他说，好吧，两件事。第一，我们需要你站得离墙更近。
Like if you can in the scene, get as close to the wall as possible because that's where the guy is with the soap coming down. The soap doesn't fall very far. So we have another take and he's like, why aren't you breaking the ornaments? I'm like, Charles, they're bouncing. What are you talking about?
如果你能在戏里做到，尽可能靠近墙，因为那是那个拿着肥皂的人掉下来的地方。肥皂掉不了多远。所以我们又拍了一遍，他说，你为什么不砸碎装饰品？我说，查尔斯，它们在弹。你在说什么？
He goes, can you throw them harder? I was like, yeah, they're just gonna bounce higher. And I was like, okay, I got it, I got it. I have an idea. So I know now we're really running out of time. So, and Michael Gallenberg had taken the most awesome photo that I have and it's the snow falling and me throwing the ornaments
他说，你能扔得更用力吗？我说，是的，它们只会弹得更高。我说，好吧，我明白了，我明白了。我有个主意。所以我知道现在我们真的没时间了。所以，迈克尔·加伦伯格拍了一张我有的最棒的照片，那是雪花飘落，我扔着装饰品，
and Charles McDougall in the distance watching me. It's the coolest. That's great, Michael Gallenberg, our set designer. Yeah, he took this photo. It was so cool. But anyway, here I am. We're running out of time. I got to stand.
查尔斯·麦克杜格尔在远处看着我。太酷了。那太棒了，迈克尔·加伦伯格，我们的布景设计师。是的，他拍了这张照片。太酷了。但不管怎样，我在这里。我们没时间了。我得站好。
I got to get myself to the wall. I got to throw these ornaments, and I need them to break. And I have to shriek, right? So I throw them with, I said, I'm going to throw them harder this time. I don't know. So I threw them as hard as I could. They bounced up higher.
我得靠近墙。我得扔这些装饰品，我需要它们碎掉。而且我得尖叫，对吧？所以我用，我说，这次我要扔得更用力。我不知道。所以我尽可能用力地扔了它们。它们弹得更高了。
I shrieked, and I just started stomping on them and shattering them with my feet. Was that your intention going in when you're like, I have an idea, I can do it, I can do it? I was thinking if I can't get them to break, I have to start stomping on them. Yes. So that's what I just did.
我尖叫着，然后我开始踩它们，用脚把它们踩碎。当你想到“我有个主意，我可以做到，我可以做到”时，那是你的初衷吗？我在想如果我不能让它们碎掉，我就得开始踩它们。是的。所以我刚才就是这么做的。
That was just an improv in the moment. I just started stomping on them. Folks notice I'm wearing my sass shoes. Oh, that's the perfect shoe for this. I know. And so I shriek, I get to the wall, I'm stomping things, I rip the box apart, we got the scene. Oh, let me tell you, ToneLoke89 is going to be very happy
那只是那一刻的即兴发挥。我只是开始踩它们。伙计们注意我穿着我的“傲慢鞋”。哦，那是这场戏的完美鞋子。我知道。所以我尖叫，我走到墙边，我踩着东西，我把盒子撕开，我们拍到了那场戏。哦，让我告诉你，ToneLoke89会非常高兴
because they wrote in with a fan question. What was that? One of my favorite scenes is when Angela screams and smashes the glass ornaments. What was it like to film? All of that. Yes, exactly. But now if you go back and watch the scene,
因为他们写了一封粉丝提问信。那是什么？我最喜欢的场景之一是安吉拉尖叫并砸碎玻璃装饰品。拍摄那场戏是什么感觉？所有这些。是的，完全正确。但现在如果你回去看那场戏，
you guys watch like the first two that I threw. I think that's kind of from the first take. They bounce straight up. So when we go back up in the office, I have to point out that when everybody decides to go to poor Richard's, Michael gets invited and the look on his face, it's better than any gift he could have been given. I know. And this is that moment where you're like, Michael has been just such a jerk this whole episode. And then you see this sort of sad wounded person that just wants people to like him.
你们看我扔的前两个。我觉得那是第一次拍摄的。它们直接弹起来了。所以当我们回到办公室时，我必须指出，当每个人决定去“可怜的理查德”酒吧时，迈克尔被邀请了，他脸上的表情，比他能得到的任何礼物都好。我知道。这就是那种时刻，你会觉得，迈克尔这一整集都是个混蛋。然后你看到了这个受伤的、悲伤的人，他只是想让人们喜欢他。
Yes. How much he needs people to invite him to have drinks. Like he needs it. Or he needs people to invite him to have drinks. Like, he needs it. Or he needs his gift to be the most popular. Yeah. He needs that acceptance. Well, we have Michael's talking head at the end, where he's talking about Christmas and gifts.
是的。他有多需要人们邀请他去喝酒。就像他需要它一样。或者他需要人们邀请他去喝酒。就像，他需要它。或者他需要他的礼物是最受欢迎的。是的。他需要那种认可。嗯，我们在最后有迈克尔的独白，他在谈论圣诞节和礼物。
Here's a little fun tidbit. This talking head was originally shot to be at the beginning of the episode. Oh. But when they were editing, they put it at the end because Greg wanted to do kind of a montage of scenes and of people leaving of us out in the snow in the parking lot. And he was like, oh, wait, that talking head,
这里有一个有趣的小花絮。这段独白最初是作为这一集的开头拍摄的。哦。但在剪辑时，他们把它放在了最后，因为格雷格想做一个场景蒙太奇，关于人们离开，关于我们在停车场雪地里的场景。他说，哦，等等，那段独白，
that works perfectly. Because something that we couldn't do, because the documentary style, you couldn't do a montage with a song. No. You had montages were set to talking heads. And we have do a montage with a song. No. You had montages were set to talking heads. And we have had a montage with song, but it's like the song playing in the car.
那非常完美。因为有些事情我们做不到，因为纪录片风格，你不能用歌曲做蒙太奇。不。蒙太奇是配上独白的。我们有——用歌曲做蒙太奇。不。蒙太奇是配上独白的。我们有配上歌曲的蒙太奇，但就像车里播放的歌曲。
Sure. Something like that. It has to be sound that is, what do they call that? Like a live sound. Like an active and a live sound. Yeah, something like that. Active sound. Yeah.
当然。类似那样。它必须是声音，他们叫那个什么？就像现场声音。就像一个活跃的现场声音。是的，类似那样。活跃声音。是的。
Before we get to the final scenes of the show, I just wanted to point out two lines that fans have quoted as some of their favorite lines ever in this episode. Oh, yes. Say them. One is, Happy birthday, Jesus. Sorry, your party is so lame. Yes. And another fan favorite is, Yankee Swap is like Machaveli meets Christmas.
在我们进入剧集的最后场景之前，我只是想指出两句粉丝们引用的这一集中他们最喜欢的台词。哦，是的。说出来吧。一句是，“生日快乐，耶稣。抱歉你的派对这么蹩脚。”是的。另一个粉丝最爱是，“洋基交换就像马基雅维利遇见圣诞节。”
And I really do want you guys to check out the DVD deleted scenes from this episode. By the way, we're not getting paid to say that. We're not. We just really think they're good. We just really think they're good. And you guys Oscar Nunez is so great with physical comedy. I did a sketch show with him before the office,
我真的希望你们去看看这一集的DVD删减片段。顺便说一句，我们说这个没钱拿。我们没有。我们只是真的觉得它们很好。我们只是真的觉得它们很好。而且伙计们，奥斯卡·努涅斯在肢体喜剧方面太棒了。我在《办公室》之前和他做过一个短剧节目，
years ago in my twenties. We've known each other forever. He is a great physical comedian, but he didn't get to do very much of that on The Office. But there is a scene in the deleted scenes where him and Creed move a desk and he gets pinned in by the desk. He has to get out from being stuck. And it's really, really funny. I want to see that. And Phyllis reveals in a deleted scene for this episode, how she met Bob. Oh, she says that they met because he works next door.
多年前在我二十多岁的时候。我们认识很久了。他是一位伟大的肢体喜剧演员，但他没能在《办公室》里做太多那样的表演。但在删减片段里有一个场景，他和克里德搬一张桌子，他被桌子夹住了。他必须从被困的地方出来。而且真的，真的很有趣。我想看那个。菲利斯在这一集的删减片段中透露了她是如何遇到鲍勃的。哦，她说他们相遇是因为他在隔壁工作。
Oh, well there you go. So there you go. They were right there together. And Kevin has a whole rap. He raps. Oh! A whole portion of a song. So really check out these deleted scenes if you can.
哦，好吧，就是这样。所以就是这样。他们就在一起。凯文有一整段说唱。他唱了。哦！一首歌的完整部分。所以如果可以的话，一定要看看这些删减片段。
They're fantastic. All right, let's talk about the final scene inside the office. All right, it happens in Michael's office. He's getting ready to leave. He's going to go downstairs. Meredith just walks into his office, takes off her top, and then Steve as Michael takes a picture and then walks out.
它们太棒了。好吧，让我们谈谈办公室里的最后一个场景。好吧，它发生在迈克尔的办公室。他准备离开了。他要下楼。梅雷迪思走进他的办公室，脱掉上衣，然后史蒂夫作为迈克尔拍了一张照片，然后走了出去。
I have a fan question. Well first of all, Kate, I really wanted Kate to be able to call in for this one. I traded texts with her, but she is starting a tour with Dancing with the Stars. Oh, yeah. She's traveling today. She's on a plane and she called me night before last and she was like, and I'm so sorry I can't come in. But she was like, I really do want to come in and talk about all things Meredith. So she will come eventually. Oh, that's good. I have a feeling you might know the answer to this fan question.
我有一个粉丝提问。嗯，首先，凯特，我真的很想让凯特能打进电话来谈谈这个。我和她交换了短信，但她要开始和《与星共舞》一起巡演了。哦，是的。她今天在旅行。她在飞机上，前天晚上她给我打电话，她说，我很抱歉我不能来。但她说，我真的很想来谈谈关于梅雷迪思的一切。所以她最终会来的。哦，那很好。我有种感觉你可能知道这个粉丝问题的答案。
OK. Carrie Schaub said, or maybe it's Carrie Shabe, said when characters flash each other, are the actors really flashing each other in real life? No, no, no. No. No. I mean, sort of.
好的。凯莉·绍布说，或者可能是凯莉·谢布，说当角色互相闪露时，演员在现实生活中真的在互相闪露吗？不，不，不。不。不。我的意思是，算是吧。
Sort of. But no. I mean, it's still embarrassing. Even if I had to like be in. I mean, it's still embarrassing. Even if I had to like be in a bathing suit, I'd feel awkward. You know what I mean? Kate was wearing pasties.
算是吧。但没有。我的意思是，这仍然很尴尬。即使我不得不像在……我的意思是，这仍然很尴尬。即使我不得不穿泳衣，我也会感到尴尬。你知道我的意思吗？凯特戴着乳贴。
Kate had things. She was kind of covered. Yeah, she had things over her hoo-has. Steve is such a gentleman. He said, Kate, I'm just gonna look at like your neck. Yeah, stare at your clavicle. They had no crew inside. Her image wasn't on any monitors anywhere.
凯特有东西。她算是被遮住了。是的，她有东西遮住她的私处。史蒂夫真是个绅士。他说，凯特，我只会看你的脖子。是的，盯着你的锁骨。他们里面没有工作人员。她的形象没有出现在任何监视器上。
That's right. And there was no chip in the digital camera. So the flash goes off. It looks like Michael's taking a picture, but there was actually never a picture taken. Never a photo. So they were very, very mindful of taking care of Kate in that moment.
没错。而且数码相机里没有芯片。所以闪光灯亮了。看起来迈克尔在拍照，但实际上从来没有拍过照片。从来没有照片。所以他们在那一刻非常、非常注意照顾凯特。
Kate would go on as Meredith to take off her clothes. Quite a bit. Quite a bit. One of my favorite things is that Kate's father wrote her a handwritten letter. Oh my goodness. And all it said, this is her father, who, you know, Kate is from Pennsylvania.
凯特后来作为梅雷迪思脱衣服。相当多。相当多。我最喜欢的事情之一是凯特的父亲给她写了一封亲笔信。哦，天哪。上面只写着，这是她父亲，你知道，凯特来自宾夕法尼亚州。
And all it said was, dear Kate, stop taking your clothes off. Love, dad. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. What did Kate do? How did she respond to that? I was like, oh man. Now is that her dad having a sense of humor
上面只写着，亲爱的凯特，别再脱衣服了。爱你的，爸爸。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。凯特做了什么？她是怎么回应的？我当时心想，哦，天哪。那是她爸爸有幽默感
or is that him being like, seriously, stop it? I think both. I think both. All right, should we talk about the parking lot? We're almost done here All right. Should we talk about the parking lot? We're almost done here. Yes. Let's talk about the parking lot because it is definitely one of the most magical moments that I remember in filming all nine years. And we all say that. Yeah. People often asked like, what were your favorite scenes? And it's always hard to explain because sometimes your favorite scene,
还是他真的在说，说真的，停下来？我觉得两者都有。我觉得两者都有。好吧，我们应该谈谈停车场吗？我们快结束了。好吧。我们应该谈谈停车场吗？我们快结束了。是的。让我们谈谈停车场，因为这绝对是我在拍摄这九年里记得的最神奇的时刻之一。我们都这么说。是的。人们经常问，你最喜欢的场景是什么？这总是很难解释，因为有时你最喜欢的场景，
it doesn't seem like that exciting of a scene, but it's what happened behind the scenes that make it your favorite. And this parking lot scene is one of mine. Definitely, definitely. Okay, so it's the end of the day. We have all of this real snow on the ground and everyone is leaving and everyone's in good spirits.
它看起来并不像一个令人兴奋的场景，但幕后发生的事情让它成为你的最爱。这个停车场场景就是我的最爱之一。绝对，绝对。好吧，所以是一天的结束。我们地上有所有这些真雪，每个人都要离开，大家情绪高涨。
And it's really nighttime. It was rare for us to ever work past 6 p.m. so we always got excited. To walk out in the dark, I think, we all felt like we were up past our bedtime. But also you have to remember this is Los Angeles. There's never snow on the ground. So this is magical in itself that we have a parking lot full of snow. And as we're walking to the cars, I don't know, like the shot you see, I'm actually in the front passenger seat of an SUV, but I'm only half in, like the doors open. But I remember one of the guys just picked up some snow
而且真的是晚上了。我们很少在下午6点以后工作，所以我们总是很兴奋。在黑暗中走出来，我想，我们都觉得我们过了睡觉时间。但你也要记住这是洛杉矶。地上从来没有雪。所以这本身就很神奇，我们有一个满是雪的停车场。当我们走向汽车时，我不知道，就像你看到的镜头，我实际上坐在SUV的前排乘客座位上，但我只进去了一半，门开着。但我记得其中一个人捡起了一些雪
and flung it at the other one. And then they all started picking up snow and having this impromptu snowball fight. And everyone loved it and they wanted us to keep doing it. But it was just sort of like us just all hanging out in the snow. Yeah. And we turned into a bunch of kids. We couldn't help it.
扔向另一个人。然后他们都开始捡雪，进行了一场即兴的打雪仗。每个人都喜欢它，他们想让我们继续做。但这就像我们都在雪地里闲逛。是的。我们变成了一群孩子。我们忍不住。
We were up past our bedtime with snow on the ground. Fresh snow on the ground. It was so fun. And you know, I have a picture of all of us together in the parking lot with Charles McDougall. And it's great. I love it. I covet it. I love that. I want to see it. Yeah. Well, this is why we have to make our scrapbook thingy, Angela. We do. We should combine. Well, that's what we need to do. We need to compile and combine all our stuff. All of our photos.
我们过了睡觉时间，地上有雪。地上有新鲜的雪。太有趣了。而且你知道，我有一张我们在停车场和查尔斯·麦克杜格尔在一起的照片。太棒了。我喜欢它。我垂涎它。我喜欢那个。我想看它。是的。嗯，这就是为什么我们必须制作我们的剪贴簿，安吉拉。我们必须做。我们应该合并。嗯，这就是我们需要做的。我们需要汇编并合并我们所有的东西。我们所有的照片。
And then make it so that we can both have what we both have. Yeah. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Before we lose it all, we need to do it. OK. It's 2020.
然后让它变成我们俩都能拥有我们俩拥有的东西。对吧？是的。是的。在我们失去它之前，我们需要做。好的。现在是2020年。
We need to do this. This is a goal for this year. I'm setting the goal for us this year. Well, you guys, she said it. Now I've got like, Jenna's gonna put me to task. This episode was really special. It was. I really hope we did it justice
我们需要做这个。这是今年我们的目标。我正在为我们设定今年的目标。好吧，伙计们，她说出来了。现在我有了，珍娜要给我布置任务了。这一集真的很特别。它确实是。我真的希望我们没有辜负它
because it means so much to us. These episodes are almost harder for me than other ones because there's so much emotion attached to it. There's so much that happens in the scene. Not only like, is it special to us personally, but it was like a big moment for our characters. And just that moment at the end, that snowball fight, that is just a group of people who love each other,
因为它对我们意义重大。这些剧集对我来说比其他的几乎更难，因为其中附带了太多的情感。场景中发生了太多事情。不仅对我们个人来说很特别，而且这对我们的角色来说也是一个重要的时刻。还有最后的那一刻，那场打雪仗，那只是一群彼此相爱的人，
who are all getting to hang out, and we just happen to be on a TV show together. It's just a really special moment. And I love that they let that be how it ended. And that's really how it felt when we left this show that we were just a bunch of friends who happened to be on a TV show together because we we were friends. And we are friends. Yeah. And we're family. We are. So next week we've got another big episode, Anne. Huge episode. I mean we listen the rest of this season two is just gonna be one
大家聚在一起，而我们恰好一起出演了一部电视剧。这真是一个非常特别的时刻。我很高兴他们让节目以这种方式结束。当我们离开这部剧时，感觉确实就是这样，我们只是一群恰好一起出演电视剧的朋友，因为我们本来就是朋友。我们确实是朋友。是的。我们是一家人。确实如此。所以下周我们还有另一集重头戏，安。非常重要的一集。我的意思是，听着，第二季剩下的部分将会是
Momentous episode after the other next up is booze cruise with our special guest Creator of the American office Greg Daniels, Greg Daniels is gonna be here. We are super excited Yeah, we cannot wait to talk to him. Thank you, Greg, in advance. And Boo's Cruise is a huge, huge episode. We'll see you next week. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration
一集接一集的重大时刻，接下来是“酒水游轮”，我们的特别嘉宾是美版《办公室》的创作者格雷格·丹尼尔斯，格雷格·丹尼尔斯将会来到这里。我们超级兴奋。是的，我们迫不及待地想和他聊天。提前感谢你，格雷格。“酒水游轮”是非常、非常重要的一集。我们下周见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwulf合作制作的。
with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Wise-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由Odyssey呈现，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·怀斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。